foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
because I heard Blake I heard the start
of it and I'm just like yeah I'm just
gonna keep hearing that like while I'm
talking at the same time and that's not
gonna work out so yeah hey everybody
It's Finally Friday this seems like an
endless week but yeah yeah here we are
woke up this morning Jen was [__]
going to work in a goddamn rainstorm it
was like [__] it was even a rain so it
was like a [__] yeah
I've been through hurricanes that
weren't as bad as that man that sucked
well it was okay so so I got up like I
leave about a little past six and it was
thundering outside but it wasn't raining
yet
and I didn't even like I don't look at
the weather or nothing like that like
probably I should not now that I had
this horrible experience this morning
but um I was like wow it's like dark as
[__] out I mean you know it's six
o'clock in the morning so it's kind of
dark as [__] but it was just like all
black clouds right so it was like it
seemed like it was the middle of the
night I get about five minutes down the
road and the [__] bottom falls out
and it's like out where we live there's
no street lights for miles and miles
it's just like a rural road so it's like
not only could I not see anything
because of the rain and the dark and
also every time somebody passed going
the opposite way their headlights would
blind me so I ran off the road a couple
of times
um because I couldn't see where I was
going
so that was special and then like the
whole and then when I was halfway there
because I'm the whole time I'm like
maybe I should turn around and go home I
should turn around and go home and then
I was like scared to like pull over I
was scared to like turn around because I
could didn't really know where I was
because I couldn't see anything and then
I had to stop and get gas because I was
almost out and I'm at the [__] Circle
K it's like a big circle K like right on
this corner it's like halfway between
here and my and my work and I was gonna
fill the tank up you know it was almost
empty and so I'm trying to fill it up
and it's like I'm standing there under
the [__] like with the with the gas pump
and it's like the rain is like sideways
and it's like smacking me in the face
and lightning is popping like literally
like all around this gas station and I
was like Jesus Christ Jesus Christ and
I'm like filling the car up and then
finally I just put like 25 30 and I was
like [__] it I'm getting back in the car
it's like I'm not filling it up I was
like I'm not standing at here getting
[__] struck by lightning so yeah that
was like really special and it was like
that the whole entire way like it didn't
let up for a second I think the only
reason I didn't die was because
thankfully there weren't that many
people on the road and everybody else
was because normally you know if you've
ever been to Florida
even people that have lived here all
their lives the second it starts to rain
everyone forgets how to drive I don't
know why that is it's extraordinary well
a lot of them are from here well that
too they can't see and but well I can't
see either but it's like so I can't see
so I slow way the [__] down because I'm
like look I'm not [__] dying on this
[__] okay it's like you know it's not
worth it but everybody else did today
too so there wasn't that much traffic on
the road because it was early in the
morning and everybody did actually like
no one was trying to be like all cool
and going hey I'm just gonna go 80 miles
an hour here you know even though it's
because there's always one [__]
that does that but nobody did it today
so everybody was going a reasonable
speed and so I made it there even though
I was like white knuckled it the whole
way holy [__] that was like [__]
terrifying right say hi to everybody I
don't think I've ever been there sitting
there what's up Grabbers I was
mentioning you the other day it was that
I was we're doing that CIA show and I
was saying his Grandpa's in there he
didn't know if you were listening or not
but you were you weren't you weren't on
the show I forgot what it was I was
gonna
gonna get confirmation with you we were
talking about the CIA I forgot what it
was so you did a show on operation but
yeah climax party yeah Tammy's in there
Zach's in there what's up what's up Zach
Camp guys in here everybody's uh coming
in you got uh they're they're all
starting to come in welcome into the
show
Friday
yay beginning of the weekend we're
already drinking hell yeah we're
probably not going we're not gonna go
out tonight we may go out tomorrow I
don't know what we're gonna see we'll
see how we feel Jen got another shipment
of clothes badass tops she's wearing one
of them now yeah show them that it's got
a little star on it yeah yeah stand up
so you can see the whole thing yeah
[Laughter]
these are you're so bossy these are some
some Hot Tops he's so bossy yeah look
look at that yes spin Jazz spin spin
look how big that [__] look how sexy
that [__] is okay she's got a bunch it
was a good stuff like that
how much did we pay it was a hundred
dollars right uh 420 actually no I
thought it was like a hundred dollars
after after rebates and tips I thought
it was more like about 70 or 80 whatever
oh okay maybe okay and for all of that I
got like 15 or 16 tops a dress a skirt
yeah and a [__] ton of different uh
stockings you had like tights and sites
and stockings yeah it's like three bucks
for a set of real [__] hot and every
single thing it's every single thing
we've got from there like we're not
sponsored by them or nothing like that
but every single thing like I tried on
because we got the shipment today and I
tried on all of the stuff like when I
got home every single thing looks good
and it all fits like perfect yeah it's
called Sheen it's an app it's an app and
it's got a really cool women's clothes
the guy's stuff's kinda
generic they got some sportswear you
know like [__] you'd wear to the gym
with you know sleeveless hoodie type
stuff with cool symbols on them that was
pretty good their paramilitary stuff
like boots and [__] like that it's cheap
I wouldn't [__] with any of that
um
it's Asian stuff you know you know how
how kind of like Asian guy stuff is real
[__]
uh skinny jeans vanilla you know so a
lot of the shit's not real age
appropriate for me and then if it's if
it's for an older crowd then it's real
[__] vanilla you know what I mean
[__] cargo shorts and [__] but if you
but for women's clothes if they got good
golf clothes I want pretty much
everything like I scroll through there
I'm like I could wear that I could wear
that like there's so much cool shade
yeah it's cheap and the quality is great
yeah I've been actually really shocked
with like even some of the tops that are
like three dollars five dollars or
something like that and I'm expecting to
be just like some throwaway piece of
paper or something like that but they're
not they're actually like really well
made no they were like something if you
went to the mall and like Hot Topic and
got it it's about that level of quality
and they would have charged you 40 or 50
bucks for that [__] back in the day oh
yeah big time yeah easily and they you
know you can get for like three three
fifty nine well what we got like the one
skirt that you got me which is kind of
this cool
um it's kind of like this structured
sure or um pleated skirt that has like a
belt like built in it's really cool
looking and I don't even remember how
much it was it was cheap it was 12. it
was 12 bucks yeah it was 12 bucks and I
didn't I didn't even realize because it
didn't even say this but it's like it's
got like it's even got like underwear
built into it it's got built-in booty
shorts and I was like get the [__] out
of here get the [__] little ass
cheeks hanging out in the bottom because
this [__] is short as [__] okay yeah
it's really cool it's just it's a booty
it's a booty band it just goes around a
booty pretty much yeah your ass cheeks
to hang out yeah you wear it to the club
well my ass cheeks are gonna hang out
I can um just something you wear the
club or shoot porn with I mean yeah I
well that's why we got it it's like I
would yeah we're either gonna shoot
scenes in it or I'm gonna wear it it's a
Barbarella I wouldn't wear it to
mannequins no because that's just asking
yeah they grope you mannequins but
Barbarella is gonna be fine yeah because
you can wear whatever you want though
you've been growing you've been groped
there for [__] without wearing
something that review yeah like I was
sitting here they had to beat the
[__] to death I was just wearing
that night I think I was just wearing um
I was just wearing my tight pants
like they weren't short it was my ass
wasn't hanging out or nothing it was
just like a pair of like tight like kind
of gothy looking leggings it was a big
dude he's probably about six one six two
probably but 230 pounds of mostly fat I
grabbed that [__] by the throat right
in front of his [__] friends and
[__] grabbed his trachy and started
pulling on him and he [__] pulled
away
and his friends are like whoa whoa and
it says and you know I considered Jen to
be my wife when I'm in a club this is
you grab my wife again like that I'm
gonna kill him
you know they're like okay all right all
right and they were old enough to know
better
those are dudes in their 40s dude
they're never old enough to know better
yeah I found it doesn't matter how old
yeah
Tran's a wonderful [__] drug I mean
well I was just like sure I don't I
guess I shouldn't have been shocked
because it's [__] mannequins you know
what I mean but
yeah I was just like I was either
dancing or I'd I just stopped dancing
and I was about to walk off the dance
floor and the dude just like walks by
just like [__] grabs my ass like that
yeah what did he think was gonna happen
no I was on that [__] instantly
because there's no way because I was
like what the [__] yeah
Tran is a special if you guys don't know
what it is if you're new to the show
whatever it's a
it's one of the nadralone Esters on the
[__] 19 Nor [__] testosterone
[__] branch and it's
it's not rated for human use it's rated
for cattle Veterinary use
and after about three or four months of
that [__] I was on it for five months I
became the [__] Goblin from [__]
Spider-Man
Soph said I was terrified but terrifying
when she when she came out here well see
that's what I would tell you but you
didn't believe it yeah but you think
you're fine you think you're no but
you're like something out of the animal
kingdom
as soon as I saw that there's no
thinking about it what should I do or
it's just instant it's like something
out of the animal I would tell you [__]
like you're scaring me and you'd be like
oh shut up or anything like that yeah
and I'm just like okay whatever out my
mind was playing tricks on me man
[__] I was driving One Time by myself
[__] and uh looked over and [__]
saw a dude in the car laughing
and I looked and I was like like that he
saw me he's like no no so what the [__]
you laughing at I'm getting ready to
jump out of traffic and [__] beat
this dude's ass I thought he was
laughing now see if I had been in the
car oh God oh God yeah yeah we're all
gonna get what I'm trying to fight this
guy we're gonna get killed yeah
right so no more Trend yeah you need to
settle down yeah yeah and it took almost
about a month to recover from it you
need to settle down
and when I tell you you're being scary
you have to believe me okay there's a
whole [__] there's a whole genre of
videos on YouTube called Trend stories
and listen to them they're hilarious
[__] uh [__] that dudes have done
when they're on tread
I'm sure there's been more than one
murder
oh yeah the dude that
broke into that house and killed that
family and started torturing that girl
to try to save the girl that he thought
they abducted was on trend
yeah but he was also see this is why
yeah but he was also he was ex-military
guy he thought that family had abducted
a girl but it was a hallucination but he
was also suffering from uh
[__] I think schizophrenia he was
suffering from some other stuff too
wasn't normal there's a video of a
[__] cop pulling a guy over in
traffic and as soon as the guy stops the
door opens up he runs dead at that cop
with a hatchet
and that cop barely had enough time put
about six rounds in him still a little
unwise he was a 220 pound [__]
bodybuilder on tread
and they don't know why he did it
Trend trend
I thought the aliens were even [__]
after him like I said yeah I saw the way
you behaved on that [__] you weren't you
didn't like you know take a hat to
attach it to anybody or anything like
that but you did kind of act like a
crazy person yeah you don't know it
yeah like I said that's the scary thing
is like you can't you know you can't
breathing yeah yeah my advice to y'all
any of you guys in the because we got
some Jim Bros here don't [__] with Trent
it's not it's really not worth it it's
cheap it's very effective
NPP is a lot better or Deca do that
which are in it's just different Esters
are the same thing but get the Esters
that are rated for human use don't go
for the veterinarian [__] yeah don't
take animal drugs no no I mean that
should go without saying well it's more
like an animal hormone it's bull
testosterone that's kind of been
modified lately like the way they behave
I don't know it's cheating on me
that was a whole other thing too yeah I
was thought people were cheating on me
yeah he was convinced yeah and I'm
sitting there I knew it wasn't true and
that was like I was still kind of mostly
working at home then I'm like where when
the [__] yeah
but they told me I'm like I'm at home in
your face like all the time yeah but
it's notorious for that yeah okay so I
had I had studied up on it I I knew it
was gonna do that all right I said look
you're gonna get [__] thinking that
people are cheating on you you're gonna
be thinking that people are talking
about you you know but I'm jotting it
down it's a hallucination okay
I had to come and check with you and
you're not cheating already
I was like [__] like that it says yeah I
thought so it's just my it's it's tread
and you're like yeah yeah I said okay
this is weird he's still kind of like
thinking about it though like yeah he's
still kind of thinking about it because
I was like like look I was like one that
that was mostly still when I was like
working from home I was like yeah where
the [__] would I yeah go like I'm here
all the time but even if I wasn't it's
like I wouldn't do that anyway yeah so
it's just like well we would talk about
it's like yeah it's not possible you're
like no no it's like when the [__] would
I do that I see you all the time you
never go anywhere yeah right yes yeah
I'm in the [__] house all the time
I'm tripping yeah yeah yeah unless you
think I'm having sex with ghosts like
that paranormal porn thing we were
talking about I knew I was tripping with
that I knew I knew that I knew I was
tripping I just had to check sex with
girls it makes you feel better to check
yeah dude yeah
[Laughter]
and I keep getting offered it all the
time because a friend of mine has a [__]
ton don't you do it if you don't even
think about it don't even think about it
and it's just so cheap and so effective
you know what I mean oh you're trying to
talk yourself
you just come to me and I'll I'll slap
you it's not worth it I'll slap you slap
it out it's not worth it it means you
can get away with it for like two months
maybe three
but by the time you're three months into
it you think you're fine oh I can do
four five six I can live on this as you
start thinking like that that's what I
mean like after a while I'm like look
I'm just gonna get murdered I'm gonna
get murdered
but you're just I was just like
[__] William Defoe from [__]
Spider-Man doing that yeah doing this
person you were saying all kind of crazy
yeah and you don't think it's crazy you
think it's totally yeah because I'm
sitting there going are you listening to
yourself
I'll cut that guy's head off yes I think
we should cut that guy's head off just
[__] weird [__] like that wouldn't that
be a good idea yeah
I think I'm about to kill that guy
it makes you very evil and very
aggressive well I think I'm gonna have
to kill him
I mean I'm not saying I haven't thought
that like if somebody did something that
pissed me off a lot but yeah just like
maybe I'll have to kill that guy yeah
luckily I never could I get away with it
luckily the only thing I did was got
into bar fights and they were they were
kind of Justified people grabbed Jan's
ass or people crowds yeah like you did
get yeah like when you did get into
fights it wasn't like unprovoked right I
mean you did just like start beating on
dudes that did yeah [__] up [__] yeah
and you are insanely strong
and absolutely no fear I mean you'll
you'll jump out and fight a damn dump
truck that's how that's how Brave you
are now that's what I'm gonna fight just
dump truck that's something I'd like
yeah yeah Tom versus yeah and you're
like um
no matter how strong you are you're
probably about 15 to 20 stronger on
Trend and a lot faster
and you're impervious to pay
and pain and pleasure kind of mix into
the same thing violence and sex kind of
blend into the same thing you're beating
a dude up and you're like kind of
getting aroused by it it's like like
BDSM it's it's
perfect go to war drug if I was back in
the [__] military and doing [__]
infantry missions and [__] and it's like
a damn near a suicide mission that
probably wouldn't survive I'd be banged
up with Trent
mad maximized Trend I'd be a [__]
death machine because you you're
probably not gonna live anyway but
maximum aggression would probably
increase your chances on a suicide
mission because you just [__]
overwhelm everybody
but uh I kind of miss it and I tell I'll
talk to Jen I was like I kind of miss
Trend it gives you the [__]
superhuman
feeling
it's habit for me so I'm not gonna do it
again the only thing and I've told you
this before I'm like this might be weird
to say but it's like the only thing I
liked about you being on Trend was that
you were actually kind of more you get
sensitive yeah yeah like well it's
really weird because you're kind of like
super aggro yeah but then you're kind of
like super emotional and like super and
I kind of liked that yeah but it wasn't
really worth no it's not worth all this
[__] well because you were like real
erratic yeah like your behavior and your
emotions were real erratic you're like
and you're a Superman yeah you well and
because you're like real paranoid
um and you were like real and like I
said I didn't really know what was going
on with you until afterward yeah because
you were telling Sophie about it but you
weren't telling me about it yeah so I'm
scared yeah so I didn't really know what
was going on so it's like all I knew was
like you kept going in your man cave and
you just be in there all the time and
like wouldn't talk to me and stuff and
I'd be like what the [__] is his deal
yeah and it's like and then you'd come
out like say crazy [__] and like and you
were all like thinking I was cheating on
you and all this other kind of stuff I'm
like what the [__] is going on yeah well
self got me through that I was like
she's cheating on me she how could she
be cheating
yeah yeah I'm tripping I'm tripping like
I said one I wouldn't do that and two
it's like it would yeah at that time it
would have been a physical impossible
it's like she don't love me it's that
kind of [__] it's that kind of [__] yeah
but see I have primed everybody
you know I told Soph this is what I'm
gonna take and this is the symptoms see
but you didn't tell me though I told you
you just did you didn't stick with you
well and and you were taking it much
longer a longer than I thought I planned
on right yeah so it was that too so I
didn't realize because it had been a
long time since you said yeah it was on
it five months right it's a five month
cycle
and it's supposed to be two to three
months maximum three I was on a five
and it took me a month and a half to
come down off of it
yeah it was special it was quite a
transformative period though
because it was kind of like climbing
Mount Everest yeah
it was real challenging kind of like the
first time doing a lot of acid
well and I kind of like too as [__] up
as it was and as [__] up as you were
on it yeah
um when you finally kind of
when we finally when you finally told me
yeah what it was and like we talked
about it and all that other kind of
stuff I feel like it kind of
I don't know like cleared the air about
a lot of things yeah maybe
yeah because I thought I was all right
right and I was like yeah you absolutely
were not all right and it's like and I
did try to tell you a few times but you
didn't listen to me so I just like
stopped you just thought I was making it
up so I just like I was like okay
whatever I'm just not gonna say anything
you're kind of at war with yourself I
don't remember everything that I was
doing and feeling at the time yeah but
she was kind of like
the aggression turns in on yourself
because you're bottling it up so you go
to war with yourself there's a lot of
like self-analysis and self-criticism
and [__] so that's partly what makes you
paranoid yeah
kind of like almost kind of like
something the Native Americans are being
into you know like uh going to the damn
tent trying to Spirit walk and [__]
you know what I mean because all the
heat getting to them and everything heat
exhausted it's like kind of like that
when you first kind of told me about it
and you were talking about
um paranoia like doubting yourself and
stuff like that I was like welcome to
woman world is like this is pretty much
how we feel all the time where you just
like always
doubting yourself and you're always like
thinking other people are like talking
about you and yeah [__] like that you
know somebody this is this what causes
Roid Rage no
Roid Rage is like uh kind of like uh
civilians
use that word a lot
but they kind of don't know what they're
talking about
um
any a lot of people don't know the
average person doesn't know what
steroids are where they come from they
just think that's they think steroids
like something that you make in a
basement somewhere it's like a chemical
you take you take it you just get big
it's nothing like that
it's a hormone it's based on
testosterone
and they rearrange the molecules
to get rid of the
androgenic effects of testosterone
and the androgenic effects are to give
you secondary male characteristics
because what they want to do is they
want to give a bunch of [__]
testosterone to males to to males
females or children
after they've taken a lot of damage
during say like a fire and they've been
burned up or they're all busted up a
doctor will give them a bunch of
steroids to increase the healing
properties the healing abilities of the
person
if you inject a bunch of [__]
testosterone a little kid a little girl
you'll [__] you'll [__] her up you know
you'll turn her into a man at age five
you know what I mean they're you can't
do it
so you want to modify it to make it less
androgenic
but you want it to be anabolic in other
words it builds muscle rebuilds tissue
so that's what steroids are they're
healing thing
well if you work out a lot and you take
those you will heal up instead of five
days or a week you'll heal up in 12
hours so you can work out every day
and grow
as long as you're eating
so if you're training
and you're taking anabolic steroids
in about three months you'll have a
Year's worth of progress in three months
because you're working out every [__]
day and you're growing
well
testosterone
and any of those anabolic steroids when
you start taking them there's kind of an
adjustment period to them
they'll kind of feel like testosterone
sometimes and you'll your aggression
will Peak
until your body normalizes and gets used
to them
so sometimes you'll lose your temper
you'll get mad if you're on a new one
until your body
gets accustomed to it takes a few days
maybe
and then your temper can kind of even
out
but it's not as bad as people think it's
just uh you become depending on how much
you're taking and what it is exactly
some of them don't do that they're not
all the same
someone will make you irritated people
will irritate you I don't want to talk
to you you know it's like that kind of
[__] well I'm like that all the time
yeah
Trend one we were just talking about
is one of the most powerful ones all
right it's five times stronger than
testosterone per se per unit
it's [__] very powerful but it's very
cheap
because it's not rated for humans it's
rated for
Animals veterinary uses they give it to
cattle so they best produce it
that's a natural loan
which is a powerful anabolic agent
they give it to cows
before they send them off a Slaughter
because they're gonna be on a train for
a couple days maybe in a week and they
don't want to lose any weight so they'll
put them on trend
so don't lose any weight on their way to
the slaughterhouse
well you could take that [__] and work
out with it it does it has a lot of
weird side effects that's why they don't
use it for humans
and rightfully so yeah and it's because
of those mental side effects
now if you're only doing it for a couple
months
and you're not doing a lot of it
the the average guy can get away with it
but the longer you're on it uh
the average guy can't handle it now
there are some guys
not everybody's the same
or some guys have the genetics for them
and for some reason they just thrive on
Trend they can take lots of it for long
periods of time and it doesn't really
affect them
it's not everybody's the same that's
something that
I guess here in the modern world
everybody wants equality and equity and
[__] but the genes don't [__] agree
there are some people that can take
things that would kill another person
but this person [__] just thrive on
it
there are some guys in there that you
just take [__] unlimited amounts of
trend and they don't seem to have any
side effects that you can see other than
that they heal up real fast
and they'll get real strong incidentally
when we're talking about equality we're
not talking about how we think
everyone's the same we think everyone
should just be afforded the same yeah
opportunities yeah but you're a high IQ
person low IQ people don't know the
difference they think everybody's the
same they'd be all the same well
they don't the average person's dumb
some people can take drugs and other
people can't so yeah they will react to
certain things and other people won't
well yeah I mean look at look at me for
Christ's sake I don't react to hardly
anything yeah yeah you're you're not a
strong responder no yeah um and I mean
which I guess in some ways is bad
although I've never really had too much
of a problem with it
um honestly on the plus side of that I
hardly ever get sick ever yeah
and like if there's flus going around if
there's colds going around I never ever
get it another thing that I wanted to
say is that
the average person thinks that if you
take steroids you're gonna look like
[__] an ifbb Pro open class
bodybuilder you're gonna be giant like
near 300 something pounds no no those
dudes that look like that first of all
take a [__] ton of stuff a [__] ton
like four or five times what I take
and they are what's called genetic hyper
responders
there's something about them genetically
no matter what they take they would get
much bigger than I would get
the dudes that didn't hyper respond to
those steroids
they're out of the competition they lost
a long time ago they never got that big
they gave up already some dudes can take
just a small amount of steroids and have
such bad side effects they can't ever
get they can't ever take them yeah like
you said yeah not everybody's different
I'm a pretty good responder if I had
been doing this maybe in my 20s or 30s
I'd gotten a lot real good results
because I'm older and I'm taking
protocols that are more for older guys
mostly just to hold you together keep
weight off you keep diabetes at Bay and
[__] like that I'm more of a therapeutic
level I'm not trying to be an ifbb
bodybuilder you know what I mean just
you know you just want to be in good
shape live a long time which is that's
some people like we live steroids are
bad for you no no there were guys that
were using all that lived into their 90s
so you just got to be very intelligent
about where you're doing and you gotta
make sure that there are limits
lit their weight limits there's limits
to how much you your body can take of
that
and a lot of it has to do with how old
you are
young guys really shouldn't be taking
any of that stuff if you're older you
can get away with it
if your genes are right and you just got
to look at your blood work and make sure
your blood pressure is good and you got
to introduce it slowly into your system
so you build a tolerance and get some of
the fat off of you and out of your
[__] system
uh and then that allows you to take a
little bit more and more and then do
more and more weights and you're working
out you know
and really
even as a professional Soldier as young
in my 20s I've never been this strong
and I'm 50 what three
uh you're going to be 54. we're going to
be 55 a week from tomorrow my birthday
yeah Tom's birthday is coming up yeah
July 1st yeah not tomorrow but it's the
following Saturday if I were to go back
in time
and meet my [__] 22 year old 101st
Airborne [__] infantry self
with my M60 and challenge myself to hand
to hand I've beat my younger self just
to death yeah
but then you wouldn't exist then I
wouldn't exist it'd be like it would be
like a size yeah but no I'm [__]
three times stronger now the thing is
when I was younger I had a lot more
endurance
psychological and physical endures I
could just do something for weeks or
months months and months on end
I could get on a [__] ninja 600 like
an 87 ninja 600 and ride it for Fort
Campbell Kentucky to Mississippi and
back in a weekend
there's like a 16 hour ride
no
no it's not that much about 12.
yeah I mean I feel like when I was
younger I had more patience for driving
long distance yes and doing that kind of
thing that was on a motorcycle I don't
really have any patience
you were never supposed to be on that
thing for a very long and that
[__] buzzed like crazy your
hands and your feet to be Numb by the
time you got there
couldn't carry much with you just had to
live off the top of the back of that
bike
yeah Tammy said just like some people
become alcoholics and others can take it
or leave it yeah yeah that's the thing I
mean we drink a lot I mean I don't know
if we drink a lot yeah we drink probably
more than the average person uh no
depends on what part of the country
you're talking depends where yeah it
depends on what you're talking about but
to be honest with you it's like I like
having a drink I like having a drink on
the show and stuff like that but if
somebody told me hey you can't drink
anymore because of Health I wouldn't
really I'd be like ah that sucks but I
wouldn't really in general me and Jen
together go through a fifth of vodka a
week
yeah that's two people so and most of
it's drunk here on the on the show
yeah we don't usually drink if we're not
doing a yeah
if we're not doing a stream
every now and then we do but it usually
will just have one yeah when I when I
was in the army in the 20s I could drink
a fifth and a night
see I would like I could do that at
night I would fall asleep no not
regularly but I was just in good shape
you know when it came to
uh my uh aerobic abilities were real
good because we ran so much you know
what I mean and [__] we drink like a
fifth party all night and then wake up
five o'clock in the morning go for
[__] eight mile run with the [__]
unit
and just the whole [__] unit would be
drinking too on some of those nights and
you can see it smell like alcohol coming
off of you can get away with all that
[__] when you couldn't get away at our
age no I mean now it's like even if we
drink it if we go out and stuff I don't
feel too bad the next day but I'm still
I don't I don't usually get hangovers
but
um I'm for sure like pretty tired you
know what I mean yeah it's like and
sometimes if I I'll even wake up early
and I'll feel okay but then like by the
time two three in the afternoon is like
oh man I need a nap like I just feel
like super duper tired
um John Smith said the question John
Smith said I beat my younger self to
death too but mainly because he was so
infuriating yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're dumb as [__]
okay I'm trying to go back Zach said
what was the last movie or show that
made you guys cry it's like honestly a
lot of stuff pretty much anything that's
sad it's like will make me cry [__] we
were watching the for the first Wonder
Woman last night and I kind of cried at
the end of that why did I cry cry but
you know what I mean yeah one woman was
pretty good I kind of teared up at the
end I want to see black women 84 next
they got all the Damned yeah hpmx has
all the because Tom last night we you
know we didn't have a stream and he and
he's like oh you want to watch a movie
and I'm like yeah what do you want to
watch and he's like oh I kind of wanted
to see the first Wonder Woman because we
never saw it yeah cause I think we were
talking about we were talking about the
Shazam and I was like oh I should check
HBO Max because if they had Shazam then
it stands to reason that they would have
the other DC ones too and they did they
had like a [__] tons they have like they
had the first Wonder Woman they have
Wonder Woman 84 they have Green Lantern
they had Batman vs Superman yeah so they
had all that kind of [__] Gal Gadot was
looking [__] hot too smoking hot
and um that was a good movie I really
liked it he's talking about steroids and
everything all those [__] actors that
are in the DC Universe they're all
they're all on gear including Gal Gadot
that's natural ohm but she's in good
shape got the right amount of weight on
her for that body style she looked great
her legs and in a slow motion shout out
to her [__] doing back kicks on
people's flips with a little [__]
sexy skirt on yeah hell yeah
and X says oh my God I actually caught
alive Yay good
day so far yo it's night time here
it's what uh I don't know you must be a
long time listener never caught alive so
welcome to the live show yeah we're
always glad when somebody that doesn't
get to catch alive gets to catch alive
and these are the funnest ones I think
okay El Padrino's asking what's our
thought on the recent black Black Rock
exposure okay yeah well you know that's
what he's talking about is uh they got a
video of a black rock executive sand oh
yeah Senators those guys are cheap as
[__] we buy them off all the time they
only cost 10 grand you can get anything
you want yeah oh yeah this this is
nothing new it's just that it's new that
it's surfaced the the normies are gonna
figure out that the highest form of
organized crime is is the government
governments are [__] criminals uh and
it's all got to be fixed and you can't
fix it we're at late stage Roman Empire
it's just got to come down
it's got to be replaced with something
that's better
but nobody's gonna agree on what's
better it's a little fragment it's going
to go down like a Soviet Empire
and Soviet Empire broke up into a bunch
of different stuff it'll be like that
it'll be based on region
nothing you can do it's just part of the
life cycle of Empires and Nations
murder Hornet said put Jen on Trend LOL
yeah I don't know what would happen
um
very few women are on Trend okay what do
you think would happen you know me uh
you'd get mean I'm already mean yeah
that's what I mean women I'd get even me
I would probably like kill someone for
sure women don't react exactly the same
way to this stuff as men do because they
they weren't androgenized
to male hormones during puberty like
guys were
and the anabolics were all based upon
testosterone basically they were
modified into three different branch
branches uh 19 Nor or nor 19 branch
which is natural the testosterone branch
which includes things like
Deanna ball
and then there's the DHT brand which is
a byproduct of it would be like anavar
and other things like that and that's
just uh those are things that are
kind of test test kind of breaks down
into DHT
well all those things don't do to a
woman exactly what they do to a man men
women have testosterone that's one of
their main hormones when it comes to
rebuilding tissue and speed and Power
but a lot of a woman's anabolic activity
is progesterone progesterone is
really doing a lot of what you see to
give it feminine shape
more or less and then Esther people said
well estrogen estrogen is there but
estrogen really
is a thing that comes into play when a
woman's pregnant it's not a main player
when a woman isn't pregnant
now what makes people look old and
become old partially is a bunch of
different things but one of the main
things is that as you as a man reaches
reaches adrenopause and a woman reaches
menopause
the production of the hormones decline a
lot
so you want to go through what's called
hormone replacement you replace those
hormones with things that are available
synthetic versions of the hormones or
anabolic steroids can also in the right
amounts and the right ones they're all
different
can replace the hormones that are
missing
to keep that person held together pretty
well or even improve that person they
got it's not like it was back in the day
you got dudes now that are in their 70s
or 80s that look [__] fantastic
I mean they're better than any 20 year
old you know what I mean and there's
like 72 and [__] just looking
shredded and great shape great blood
work
because they're not abusing it they're
just using it
um they know how to use it
this is all newer stuff in the last 15
years that they're learning how to do
um will they kill you uh well when
you're 70 what's your life expectancy
life will kill you life will kill you
yeah if if you're 50 life experience
life your life expectancy is 25 years on
top of that 20 maybe depending on where
you live so you how's this [__] gonna
hurt you how is it if anything it'll
help you because it'll get fat off you
um and you know obesity will be a lot
less of a problem
so heart attacks it's just that how you
introduce it into the body your training
regimen and
getting yourself back strong enough to
take more there's you just got to be
intelligent somebody's uh yeah I was
trying to what'd you say uh thank you
very much Jeffy art very generous Super
Chat thank you yeah after my weekend
night job as bar security okay good luck
with that so I'll catch you guys
tomorrow by reruns thank you for the
content as it always keeps me
entertained thank you very much we do
try to entertain you
Tammy says uh my kid's father drank
himself to death at 45. he couldn't
leave the booze alone I can drink and
then not touch it again for weeks or
months yeah I'm kind of the same like I
said I do like to drink but if you know
if I didn't have any money or it's like
or we couldn't go out or we could didn't
have money to like buy any booze or
anything like that it'd be kind of a
bummer but I wouldn't be that worried
about it to be honest with you
so it's like I don't think I have the
gene for
addictive no you don't have the
addictive behavior
but some people do and that's and it's
like harder for them but it's like I
don't think I have that because it's
like yeah I could take it or leave it
it's fine some people can get addicted
easily other people are a little more
resistant yeah Camp guy said I knew
someone who was really sensitive to
alcohol only took her two years to drink
herself to death and she was a nurse
yeah yeah
it's like I said it can happen it can
happen
so that's kind of shitty but
uh Camp guy said I sometimes cry at the
end of It's a Wonderful Life yeah like I
said any movie that is like really sad
or has like a super super uplifting
ending then I'm probably gonna cry at
that [__] because that's just how I roll
for some reason I thought of
I think I thought of this because
somebody was I was on Facebook the other
day and some like in a horror group that
I'm on
and somebody's asking like uh what's the
saddest horror movie you've ever seen
and I said um I legit ugly cried at the
end of trying to Busan yeah holy [__]
that was so sad that's a great [__]
movie but [__] what a [__] oh that
was such a sad end El padrino was asking
me uh what What's my thoughts on
reporter James O'Keefe I'm not sure
what's going on with James of Keith you
have to refresh me in the comment
section I don't know what happened
you can have the jog my memory
murder Hornet put the little thing that
says little Tom Wants More Trend yeah
he's he's Tom's playing no [__] uh
MPP is more like I said if you ever have
better if you ever have the idea to go
back on that just come and tell me and
I'll slap you in the face yeah
it's not worth it you can just take MPP
or Deca it's the same thing it's just a
different Esther of it
and it's one that's a lot better on the
human system
John Smith said my grandfather turned
108 last week I still wouldn't tangle
with him
holy [__]
that's way above that's holy crap
But to answer somebody's question about
the Roid Rage I've pretty much done them
all all the main ones yeah he has yeah
and uh only the only one that [__]
with me was Trend the rest of them were
piece of cake
um adjusting to testosterone high levels
of testosterone that took a while
it wasn't rage it was just
um trying to get laid trying to get
[__] ass off of Jenny constantly
that's one of the things they drive her
crazy
um yeah it was like I couldn't ever like
I couldn't get any sleep I couldn't like
[__] do anything like I said I'm I'm
working in mines and he would just like
come in there and start spawning and
groping yeah and I'm just like dude I
got I I have [__] to do yeah and you do
it even when you weren't that aroused so
she's like okay do it you're like well
not really hard it didn't [__] it and
she's like God damn it now I have to lay
here for like an hour you know I really
didn't think this through like reading a
book I didn't think it's through I want
to [__] but I'm not really aroused it's
just because
I always kind of suspected I know this
is gonna sound bad but I always kind of
suspected that when you were on that
[__] that you were just out like [__]
anything that moved what's that that
you're out [__] anything that moves
no because you kind of went like you're
trying to
but it's it's kind of like not all of
this the
the switches are being tripped like the
desire and the behavior is there but not
necessarily the motivation to do it or
not necessarily like the [__] you're
not really getting the hard on to do it
right and it's because like only
sometimes only like half of the switches
are tripped right you know what I mean
uh it's kind of like yeah I'm a I'm
gonna [__] the [__] out of [__]
but
only only [__] half of the [__]
signals are being said you're not rocked
up or anything you know what I mean
they're like oh she's gonna let me do it
okay hold on one second let me hold on
let's get this started
I thought you were gonna say no
that kind of [__] it's that it's that
kind of feeling because it's not the
same
but but that's because and but thing is
it's like that was like uh
that was when I was on uh trt doses of
it I was only on 200 milligrams test a
week cypionate that's what they were
giving me from the clinic
and there's like an adjustment period
probably like
didn't really hit me until like month
two
and then uh that first year you'd had
kind of these weird [__] like a weird
adjustment periods you were going
through because you were like rebuilding
yourself
um
year two was a lot easier but then I was
realizing man I can get this [__]
[__] over-the-counter stuff from
other countries a lot cheaper than what
these clinics are given to so I started
going overseas to get my [__] you know
there's ways to get it here
I was get and I was going like he was
only giving me 200 you know but you know
at my age and what these other dudes are
doing they're saying like 400 is a lot
better so I started doing like 400 300
and 400 and by then your system's
already primed
so and already knows what to do with
what it is you're injected and that's
when I really started seeing progress
when I was doing like more like 400.
and then I'm going you know what
I'm gonna throw in some [__] anavar
on top of this which is that's an oral
steroid pills and I said I'm gonna try
some win straw like it is good you know
what I'm gonna [__] inject some Diana
ball
danabal was real good Tom's making bad
decisions yeah no yeah dannibal is just
another it's just super testosterone the
model the the molecule looks just like
testosterone is just stronger but it
dramatizes into methyl estrogen which is
like an estradiol but it's harder for
your system to get rid of so you start
blowing up like a [__] Michelin man
you feel sexy as [__] you walk around
with constant chubby
rocking like you're the tomcat and
everything you're like yeah we use it
but you're [__] look like [__] you
get rid of your face face gets big
around as a [__] balloon you gotta
have [__] estrogen blockers I didn't
have them
at the time so I I said [__] it I just
work it out
and I said yeah I look bloated but I
don't care I only got another month left
or you know three weeks left of this
[__] that'll come off of it
uh I wasn't a guy that didn't really
have to worry about gynecomastia too
much I never really had
I'm not estrogen sensitive in terms of
[__] like growing tits or anything I
watched for all that I I did yeah I can
get away with it I'll nip up a little
bit after
injections you know what I mean so you
have to watch what it is you're doing
so uh I don't know it's just fine
uh Camp guy said her bow Meister oh that
[__] only had sex six times with
his wife in over 20 years
really is that true like I know he did a
show about him and I remember hearing
about that but yeah holy crap
Jesus then Camp guy said I would have
went for sex ever six times in the first
two or three weeks of my wife exactly I
mean [__]
that's like
yeah I I kind of figure like that that
would be like just a week okay
watch that's 20 years I can't imagine I
can't imagine going that long it's like
I know that other that people have
different
I was you know I'm not excusing her
bowmeister obviously because he was like
a serial killer and a [__] but
you know what I mean I know that some
people are
not as are more like asexual I get that
but I don't I don't understand that I've
never been like that ever but
uh yeah so John Smith is talking about
his 108 year old growth that is amazing
108 [__] hell so he does have the
witch one or you again looking at his
100 plus Grand and great grandchildren
well you can't blame the dude though
because honestly look I'm 50. and I have
um how many cousins
I don't even know how many cousins I
have okay but it's not a hundred that's
for sure but it's a lot
um I don't even remember all the names I
don't remember their names I don't
remember their
um their their spouse's names I don't
remember their whose kids or whose I
don't remember so and it's like and I'll
have Dementia or nothing like that I
don't think
so if it's a [__] man if you're 108 you
can forget some [__] it's fine it's fine
I forget [__] all the time and I'm at
that age it's either less than half that
age
I don't know if I would I would have
lived to 108
I guess it would depend I guess it would
depend
some days
I don't know I guess it depends on the
day because some days I'm thinking oh I
could live another conceivably I could
live another 40 50 years and then some
days I'm like oh man that makes you just
like feel really tired but then some
days I'm like yeah man I'm gonna live
that long but it's like I don't know I
guess it would depend like on what kind
of shape you're in you know as long as
she didn't have any
health problems or anything like that
that were making your life difficult
but if you're saying how John Smithson
is 108 year old grandfather Yeah was
like couldn't remember which grandchild
or great grandchild I'm like [__] man
it's like I'm 50 and I can't remember
all my [__] relatives names so yeah
that's fine
that's fine people will live a long time
in the future as long as everything's
stable in society and you can be able to
get some of these new things that are
coming out
um even though
a lot of the stuff that would help out
life extension has been around for a
long long time I mean Jacqueline lived I
lived I think 94. he was in his 90s yeah
and he
he died pretty strong you know when when
he died he was still looked pretty good
best for 94.
some people were like well how the hell
do you do this all that exercise anyway
yeah and test and anavar he liked anavar
he never got big he never broke weight
limits or anything and that's a hell
that's really one of the keys is that
you don't want to get too heavy
well yeah because your heart has to deal
with all of that weight whether it's fat
or muscle right I mean muscle's better
obviously but it's like it's still wait
it's still like working I really have no
plans to break 200 pounds I mean if I
was 190 pounds
15 body fat I'd be [__] happy I could
live like that I could live like that
the rest of my life I'm not trying to be
220 pounds the five six yeah 220 that's
that's bigger than [__] [__] um
oh Arnie's little buddy what was his
name [__] uh
[__] dude from Sardinia
I mean he was a [__] he was the
lightweight champion
um I'll remember his name
later and he was a strong [__]
he was stronger than Arnold on in in a
strong man competition back in the 70s
he was in uh Conan and everything he
played the [__] little Scout oh right
right I don't know who you're talking
about I can't remember his name though
what was his name that was Arnie's best
friend back in the day
I think we talked about him on that yeah
a long time ago but I almost said his
name almost remembered it but he at his
top he was only 200 pounds 198 190
because he couldn't break 200 that was
the that was the lightweight limit
it's like five percent body fat 200
pounds he looked at him he looked better
than Arnold [__] looked great
um
I'm waiting for somebody to drop his
name in there
but uh and I'll never look that that
good because he started when he was
young all right so man if I was
190 185 maybe right now I weigh about
177.
but I got some I got some fat on me I
could lose
I'm just re recomposition recop it
lose the weight in replacement with
muscle losing fat replacing with muscle
if I was 185
15 body fat I'd be [__] happy and you
could live like that a long long time
it's not stressing your heart out
you don't want a bit and you do not want
to break a 230 pounds really
240 pounds and get anything under
if you're under five percent body fat
man you're really or five five percent
body fat and under you're really [__]
pushing it you it's not really good for
you you got to have more fat than that
on you gotta place to store water you do
need fat yeah yeah and and it's just
yeah you look good but [__] you're gonna
[__] fall out on the dance floor at
the [__] club drinking them [__]
alcohol and the [__] taking your damn
water pills [__] pass out from
dehydration and
eight the [__] ambulance is going to
come in and thinking oh he's on steroids
he's having a heart attack and start
treating you for a heart attack instead
of giving you [__] fluids and they
kill you that's been that's usually when
it happens
he's got to be having a heart attack
yeah no it's dehydration yeah you didn't
have any [__] fat nowhere to store
any with fluid been dancing all night
drinking alcohol he's [__] on a half
full of [__] diuretic [__] pills
trying to look shredded for the chicks
yeah
um let's see uh Camp guy brings up the
novel the corrections by Jonathan
Franzen which was a great book actually
um I need to reread that I read it a
couple uh years ago but yeah murder
Hornet said my mom warned me when I was
young the older I get the worse the
hangovers will be she was right
um that's right Franco Colombo thank you
very much thank you very much John Smith
Franco Franco Colombo and he was a
[__] Champion man Franco was good
looking little dude he was even shorter
than me I think he was five foot three
or five four
and couldn't break 200 pounds or he or
he'd end up having to compete with the
big guys I think about 200 pounds five
percent body fat he looked like a god
yeah anyway the heavyweight and the
lightweight champion they were like best
friends Arnie and [__] Frank a lot of
photos of them together man if you look
at them side by side
Franco looked better than Arnie he was
smaller but he looked better his
proportions were [__] amazing
what I was gonna say is that
um one trick I don't know if this will
work for everybody but a friend of ours
who is
um younger than us but is a seasoned
Drinker as well as a seasoned drug taker
um his secret is he's like you know
obviously drink a lot of water like
while you're drinking that's a good
thing too you should eat a fatty meal
beforehand also don't try to do it after
it doesn't work as good but one thing I
found that works really good is if
you're drunk when you get home before
you go to sleep and it has to be before
you go to sleep take three painkillers
either aspirin or ibuprofen Works uh
they both work equally well and
um I have found that that has actually
helped to Stave off hangovers it doesn't
help Stave off tiredness like usually
I'll still be tired like the following
afternoon but I won't feel like complete
ass like the next day as long as you
remember to take the [__] you have to
take it before you go to sleep though
like you can't like wake up and be like
oh I feel like crap I'm gonna take
aspirin or ibuprofen it doesn't work
then you have to do it before you go to
sleep and then it works but like I said
I don't know if it'll work on everybody
but it works on me so I haven't had a
hangover in a while
but I am tired like the next day but
that's about it I don't feel too crappy
Zach says uh speaking of movies I cried
uh ugly cried multiple times during
hereditary that one didn't really make
me cry it just stressed me the [__] out
and it stressed me the [__] out so much
that I really wanted to watch it a
second time but I was like afraid to
for like two years how long did it take
me to like watch it a second to like to
build up the [__] gumption to watch
it because I'm like man that movie was
so awesome but God it just it made me
feel so bad like it made me feel so
anxious and it just made me like it just
stressed me out it gave me nightmares
and stuff like that and then I was just
kind of like I want to watch it again
because I know there's a lot of stuff
that I missed but I kind of didn't want
to because I was like I don't know if I
want to feel like that again but I did
kind of I did finally like watch it
again but like I said it didn't it
didn't necessarily make me want to cry
but it did like give me really really
bad anxiety and it gave me like really
bad um nightmares I'll say which horror
movies don't
usually do
that was the first one that had done
that in a really long time a really long
time
um I can't even think of the ones what
I'm trying to think of like a movie that
had given me nightmares prior to that
and I can't really think of one ever not
since I was a kid
I mean when I was younger like the first
few times I Saw The Shining
um that gave me nightmares like you know
because I first saw it when I was [__]
too young to watch it probably
I don't know 10 11 something like that I
think was the first time I saw it and
that especially the whole scene in like
the bathroom with like the lady in the
tub and everything like that oh that
stressed me the [__] out and um the
whole thing with like the kid's voice
like rad rap like that I don't know why
that freaks me out but that freaked me
out and so the first few times I Saw The
Shining like that gave me nightmares but
that's when I was a kid
I don't really remember another movie
giving me nightmares oh no maybe the
ring did
another Japanese one I saw the Japanese
well I saw the American remake first the
gore verbinsky one and I saw that in the
theater and that movie [__] stressed
me out too
which like I said they don't usually but
that one kind of stressed me out for
whatever reason and then I was like well
I should probably watch the Japanese
original ring you and I watched that and
I was like that was good but it wasn't
it wasn't nearly as scary I didn't think
I mean I you know I know everybody has
like a different thing and some people
like the Japanese one better I get that
but and I'm usually not a big fan of
that whole uh that whole period where
they were remaking like every Asian
horror movie like in an American version
because most of them were okay but they
weren't as good but I would argue that
out of those the ring the American
version was better than the Japanese one
I think I just you know and if you want
to argue otherwise that's I'm not gonna
get mad about it or anything like that
but I just thought the American one was
like way scarier but in most instances
the Asian version was much better but in
that case I think the American one was
better but that movie stressed me the
[__] out too but that was the and when
the [__] did that come out 2002
something like that because whenever I
saw that in the theater and that scared
the [__] out of me too but that was the
last one that did that before hereditary
so how long so that's 16 years in
between I'm always looking for that
though because I'm into horror right and
it's like I love horror movies they
don't have to scare me or nothing like
that I just enjoy them but I'm always
looking for that movie that's gonna like
traumatize me you know what I mean and
it's like I hate it but I also kind of
love it at the same time and it's rare
that it happens but that's why I like
hereditary so much because I'm like hey
you got me you did it like and it's
that's very rare for like I don't know
first time I saw the movies in the
theater and it kind of overloaded me I
just thought it was ridiculous
I saw the second time though and it was
better I liked a lot better that same
director though did [__] his uh
mid-summer Midsummer and I like I love
that movie
Midsummer was also great oh yeah because
I was like okay all right yeah he's
going he's going the Wicker man route
and mid-summer is really good
yeah that little actress I love that
little that little one that played
Florence Pier yeah yeah played fighting
with my family yeah she's the cutest
[__] yeah adorable little chick and uh
there's just something about her she's a
good actress every time we see her in a
movie Tom's like I love her head yeah
yeah she's got a great head it's like a
big head she's little she's little and
she's like she looks like a bobble head
yeah yeah I want to say like a
bobblehead she looked like a lollipop
she's got this big cute head she looks
uh neotenous
yeah I think that's what it is yeah
she's my honest because she has like a
feeling yeah and then she did a great
job as [__] um
uh that uh British wrestler chick from
yeah and it was a Florida movie it was
fighting with my family she Paige Paige
she played Paige and did it was a
feel-good movie I really recommend that
move if you guys have never seen fight
with my family you want a good feel-good
movie with a a female character who's
kind of downtrodden from a kind of a
cool British family of Misfits who were
like wrestlers and
she comes to Florida
to become a pro wrestler and [__] has
a hard time but makes it you know I mean
[__] The Rock shows up in it
um
it's and it's based on the true story
it's based on Paige yeah
who is this [__] goth wrestler chick
and um she's
Florence plays her and [__] she was
like a British goth chick [__] her
mom was goth in the movie
yeah yeah
but it's uh and it's shows a bunch of
locations where me and Jim would [__]
hang out and pass by every day or wear
the club like I said that was like Hey
we've been there
look at the freeway there look there we
are we're prepared
yeah we probably were at that point
uh John John Gore said was she a neon
demon I don't think she was was she
Indian demon you didn't see that but I
did
I don't remember I don't know if you'd
like it it's weird as [__] yeah I loved
it but yeah that's that that was my
thing that's my jam like I love all
those [__] weird ass movies like that
I said Miss summer with John Cusack no
no he wasn't in them phew Henderson was
a he was sorry watching
he's working and he's typing he's
sneaking that's why he's at work okay
all right yeah we won't tell no um
Midsummer was a
a folk horror movie midsomar yeah
midsomar
it uh had pew pew what's her name
Lawrence P Florence Pugh have Florence
Pugh in it and she's she's cute as [__]
in it and uh she's with a group of
University students they're gonna study
this cult that's living out in the woods
yeah like well they don't live in the
woods but it's like a village it's like
a village yeah the village is out in the
woods though
Kinda Yeah you know it's like a Farmland
yeah and it's like wicker man and
[__] weird [__] happens including all
kinds of like human sacrifices and [__]
and uh they're like friendly but they
got rules it's you got to see it it's
good it's good it's uh same dude same
director that did hereditary hereditary
he's got other movies though didn't he
would I like him I don't know
you don't think I'd like them well it's
hard to say okay because like I said
it's it's hard to say I love like Artie
[__] I love all that kind of stuff and
like you sometimes like it and sometimes
not it depends on what it is it depends
on what it is it's like hard to tell I
don't like I just automatically love
anything just because it's already or
anything like that like it has to Vibe
with me but I've seen hereditary three
times I think and I warmed up to it I
didn't like the first time I saw it I
fell asleep during it you did yeah you
fell asleep
but I really like mid-summer second half
[__] came on we saw it live in
the theater and I was like oh yeah I
think we saw it twice in this song
because he liked it so much though
some other movies she took me to think
she she took me to see that she thought
I'd hate and they were like my favorite
movies now like uh [__] art of
self-defense
uh [__] I love that movie yeah which
I thought he would hate that like what
we were watching it I really dug it I
thought it was hilarious I didn't know
what to make because I'm watching I'm
analyzing it because I was like oh my
God Tom's gonna hate this [__] movie
but he loved it yeah no no because I
understood it it's hard to tell I
understand I understood what the dude
was talking about and it was true but
he's talking about there's a lot of
truth to it now that particular director
you know he's I guess he's just wimpy as
[__] there's a bunch of [__] about him
but uh if he's listening to it [__]
if he's listening to the show I'm gonna
say you know they say you're a puss you
know what I mean but I tell you what
that was a great movie you got it right
it's about a warrior occults and the
thinkings behind him that dovetails
right in with my experience in the
military and it dovetails right in with
[__]
count Dante and the [__] black dragon
Society if you know martial arts that's
what he's talking about it was just
brilliant brilliant his take on it is
correct but my interpretation of his
Tech my appreciation and interpretation
of his Tech of his take on it
we're agreeing but we're agreeing for
different reasons you know I'm talking
about I have personal experience with
that you know what I mean I think he's
kind of making fun of it but I make fun
of it too but for different reasons I
think he is making fun of it we're both
making it it's a black comedy it's a
black com we're both making fun of it
but I make he's making fun of it as an
outsider looking at it I'm making fun of
it as yeah I was in that [__] kind of
like I understand exactly what you're
talking about yeah yeah we'll see that
just goes to show that you don't
necessarily have to be like in something
to like understand it from a writer's
perspective yeah you know what I mean
yeah
John Smith said the last movie they gave
me a nightmare was the digestion scene
in nope that was a pretty great uh scene
actually gonna say I didn't like nope as
much as Jordan peele's other movies
um I much preferred get out and us but
that's usually because I'm not super
into sci-fi and I don't usually like
aliens as baddies I did like the angle
of that one
um like because he did something
original with it but I'm gonna like more
straight up horror than I am like sci-fi
always El padrino said Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the original [__] me up I
don't like rural areas
yeah ahead during that movie back in
high school
yeah yeah it was kind of disturbing in a
way I'm down in the basement getting
head from from a hot ready and then and
the grafters know who's who knows she's
just like screaming yeah yeah
ignore the screen trying to kind of
ignore the screen looking at this
[__] hot red head that [__] it
yeah
yeah okay so um that's that movie yeah
you can really tell I mean Toby Hooper
did it and it's like they shot it in
Texas it was like 120 degrees or some
ridiculous [__] they didn't have any air
conditioning they had been shooting for
like hours and hours like the behind the
scenes [__] you can tell that everyone
is kind of going a little bit crazy at
that point and that really comes out in
the final product I think that's kind of
why so many people still resonate with
that movie nowadays because you can
legit like it looks like they're really
going through some [__] you know say uh
Hornet man he said Hornets I know the
dim mock you're like I don't know if
you've seen
um uh [__] uh
art of self-defense but man you should
see it it's a great flick it's a trip
it's a comedy but it it's real man and
that's like exactly my sense of humor
yeah it's just it's very dry yeah it's
[__] and it's very sarcastic I own it
man and it's very it's kind of like
low-key or like understated but it's
like I don't know I just found I just
like busted up laughing like a bunch of
times yeah I own it I'm talking about it
makes me want to see it again
okay John Smith said I know this is
heresy in certain parts but I prefer the
US remake of the Ring I do too like I
said I saw the US one first and that
movie scared the crap out of me like
when I first saw like in 2002 it really
really did a number on me and then I
said and I figured well I'll watch the
Japanese one because you know you got to
and I liked it but not as much now I
will say that I've also seen like I
prefer the Asian versions of like the US
version of The Grudge with uh Sarah
Michelle Geller that was pretty good
um but the Asian one was better you know
what I mean and one that I actually I
really like and I recommend if you
haven't seen it it's not actually
Japanese I think it's Thai
um but it's called The Eye and they did
an American remake of it which was not
good I think [__] it was in a Jessica
Alba or somebody like that but whatever
but it's like see the tie one because
that one was like really good there was
like a couple there was a scene in there
if you've seen it there's a scene in
there in an elevator that's one of the
creepiest [__] things that I've ever
seen ever it's really really good
um and then who wait where was it oh
John Smith said though as a kid the gate
scared the crap out of me I really like
that movie that what that came out in 87
so I was like a little bit older but we
did a um review of it I still think my
favorite moment in that is like when the
farmer guy like Falls over and then like
he turns into all those little demons
yeah I love the little demons in that
I've I haven't seen it in a while and I
didn't see it when it came out so it
didn't make a big impression on me but I
I liked it when I watched it but I don't
remember much about it that was the one
where the guy found the hole in the
ground right it was kids they were like
yeah with kids and like they played the
like heavy metal record backward or
something like that and it's like they
open up like yeah and they've ever
likened it it's like it's like a y a
horror movie
um so it's a good so I mean if you have
kids and you want to get them into
horror because I know that's a whole
thing but that's a good one to start
with I was I would if you want to go in
the 80s row I would go like the gate
Monster Squad the lady
Fright Night
that might be a little you might have to
be a little bit older for that one
because that's got some kind of [__]
up [__] in it but um
but yeah like other than that because
Friday night wasn't really made more
comments and stuff I know well yeah
oh yeah Elle Fanning she was the one
that was a neon demon if you haven't
seen neon demon I just don't like if
you're into already [__] like I am like
you probably like neon demon I liked it
but I don't I don't know if you would
like it maybe you would like it I'm not
sure
I'm not sure I can never tell
um Camp guy said Cusack's best movie is
Being John Malkovich yeah I mean John
Cusack was in a [__] ton of good men and
I incidentally I Just re-watched Being
John Malkovich I saw that in the theater
and then I saw it again on cable and I
saw that it was on uh
oh it's coming down here yeah I know we
just got hit by a storm if we lose what
else is a stream you'll know why yeah
um but yeah I just saw that it was on
one of my streaming services one night
and he was at bike night or something
and I said [__] man I'm gonna re-watch
Being John Malkovich because I'm really
liking this movie and man
I forgot how [__] hilarious that
movie is I love how
I mean the concept is just
out there you know what I mean but it's
just they pulled it off like so well
it's I just forgot how like [__]
funny it was
um and he also said I liked identity
yeah that was also a great movie that
was another one we rewatched not too
long ago because I think we did a review
of it
um and they're also talking about Beau
is afraid yeah it's like I kind of want
to see that I've heard mixed reviews so
I mean I'm gonna watch it but you know
we'll see how that goes and they're
talking about angel heart which is also
great
um we did a review of that probably a
couple years ago I think
John Gore said has Tom seen city of God
I think he'd like it I saw that I saw
the trailer yeah I seen it but it was a
long time ago I haven't seen city of God
I haven't seen [__] blood diamonds I
think that's also good I saw it on an
airplane though so I wouldn't mind
seeing it like if anybody wants us to
review that if you send those to us you
can send us to it through Amazon and
just have it delivered here we can give
you the address we'll review it but we
got [__] in line
that's something I want to see
yeah I think you would probably like
that I haven't seen it in a long time
yeah send it to me on Blu-ray and I'll
[__] will review it we'll move to the
frontal line okay yeah
but um but yeah being John Mac it was
like all that weird [__] that was
Spike Jones though wasn't it I was
thinking it was Charlie Kaufman but I
guess not because I was thinking of
other Charlie Kaufman movies like cynic
dose New York see here's the thing
I built the blood diamond Carby and I
got one
xm177 or in other words a little [__]
car 15. I've seen the [__] scene of
him with the [__] blood it's it's an
AR-15 short barrel I got one
and I built it to look just like that
uh but I've never seen the movie
it's just that that movie happened to
have
one of my favorite iterations of the
[__] AR-15 of the or the car I feel
like you would probably like that movie
yeah like I said I honored DiCaprio yeah
I've only seen it once and like I said I
saw it on an airplane so you can't
really like concentrate on it yeah but I
remember it being really good I want to
see blood diamonds and I want to see
city of gov yeah there's a couple other
ones out there that if my memory got
charred I remember but they're that same
kind of thing
2000s Era military Adventures you know
um
because I think blood diamonds came out
in what 2003 something like that
somewhere around there it was when I was
going back and forth to you to the UK a
lot yeah so it probably would have been
yeah around there it was around the same
time as city of God I'd probably 2004 or
2005 something like that yeah
Tyler the guy said the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre doesn't feel like a movie it
feels like you're watching something
that actually happened yeah yeah it kind
of does and I think that's one of the
things that made it so iconic was that
you can literally when you watch that
you can literally like smell that movie
you know what I mean yeah it's just
I'm just glad that movies aren't scratch
and sniff because that movie would just
smell like head cheese and sweat and
blood and [__] and it would just be like
you know what I mean
it's just it's like that it's like that
and it's you know what the Remake that
they when did they do the Remake
2004-ish I saw the Remake and I think I
might have actually even gone to the
theater and seen it the Remake wasn't
bad
um I didn't mind it actually it was one
of the better remakes that they did in
the early 2000s because they were doing
all those [__] remakes then but um
that was probably the best out of the
bunch I think other than maybe like Dawn
of the Dead
um but you're never gonna replicate that
look and that feel you know what I mean
because yeah you can try and do it but
it's gonna be fake I mean the way that
they did it they shot it for
very little money like I said and they
really did go through all that [__] it's
like there really was like [__]
rotten meat on the table that had been
sitting there for like because they
couldn't afford to get more so it was
just like sitting there like in the
[__] 120 degree Texas summer and they
were all like sitting there with rotting
me and they were all just like going
crazy and like shooting for hours and
hours a day and everyone was just like
losing their mind so it's just kind of
like you're never gonna
replicate that that magic that was like
lightning in a bottle you know what I
mean I'm sure it wasn't fun for the
actors but it it made it a classic movie
so I guess it was all I guess it was all
okay
um yeah Camp guy said Cameron Crow
movies are good yeah yeah Almost Famous
I really liked I remember seeing that in
the theater as well Vanilla Sky I don't
think I saw because wasn't that that's a
remake right of um open your eyes the
Spanish film
I've seen that but I don't think I've
seen vanilla's guy
um let's see City yeah El pedrino said
city of God is great you'll like it Tom
okay well send it to me man
if not wait forever problem we'll never
get around to uh we're on a live stream
I can't show any Firearms full firearms
on a live stream but I can show Parts
okay I don't think the AI will have a
problem with this is the blood type of
carbine but this one has um an empty
suppressor can pinned and welded welded
to it so I could get that 16 inch
overall length and not have to apply for
SBR
that's my city of God
or excuse me uh Blood Diamond carbine
upper
nice huh the problem is I couldn't get
the um
fixed carry handle
version of the upper so I had to use the
uh an A4 Style
with screws on where you know we're kind
of uh clamps on
[__] no uh what was that there was a
company that was gonna gonna start to
make PSA is going to start to make carry
handle uppers
and once they start making them all uh
probably put a carry handle up around
that because that's actually a two-piece
uar 15 guys know what I'm talking about
El padrino said where am I sending
um I guess like well yeah either contact
me or Tom and we'll give you like we'll
give you the address address as long as
you don't show up in stock yes and what
you can do what you can do is you can
just go on Amazon and buy the Blu-ray
and have the delivery just put our
address and it'll show up here it'll
take one day or two days and you'll go
right to the front of the line with the
review
we don't have um anybody else waiting
right now I don't think well I'm still
working on we're still working on big
basis Hotel yeah and what else do we
have out I think that's it right I think
so I think that's it yeah
I think that's the only movie that well
it's not a movie but it's a series never
finished the second season of Rome that
you gave me yeah I gave you that for
Christmas I know two years ago I think
yeah I don't even think it was last
Christmas it might have been the
Christmas before right we started
watching it we got really into it and
then like we just didn't [__] I want
the whole [__] four seasons of
Spartacus
on Blu-ray yeah I liked that it was a
[__] great I even liked the [__]
last season without the [__] main guy
when they replaced him he was still good
well yeah he died yeah
um yeah John Gore said The Hills Have
Eyes remake was all right yeah it was
okay
um yeah John Smith said the Remake is
decent that the group mostly looks like
models I think that's kind of the
problem that was kind of the problem
that I had with a lot of the early 2000s
remakes of like all the classic because
they remade
Friday the 13th and they remade uh
Nightmare on Elm Street with that stupid
looking Freddy I don't know what they
were thinking with that yeah
he's asking me to please review what now
the vice squad with wings Hauser if you
send us a Blu-ray it will move to the
front of the line
and we will review it if we get a
Blu-ray we will review it
and you'll move to the front of the line
otherwise we'll just pick them up
otherwise we'll just pick a movie at
random and we pick movies or we have to
go back into the back catalog but
whoever sends us something your [__]
moves to the front and we got a pretty
steady line I mean [__] um
xanado sent us a [__] ton of movies
lately yeah he's on his casino and he
yeah he sent us like a lot of um a lot
of gangster movies a lot of gangster
movies so we did like a lot of those and
keep in mind too that if you don't know
I do reviews
also usually of horror movies or
Thrillers
um I've been doing I've like the last
few weeks I've been working on like 50s
ones yeah Facebook you can find it find
her on Facebook yeah yeah like um if you
didn't see it like last weekend I posted
um a review of Night of the demon AKA
curse of the demon from 1957 which is a
movie that I like uh Jacques tornor
which I've been wanting to see for a
long time so I did a review of that and
I'm gonna do
um I have I have it all written out I
just haven't recorded the I just haven't
recorded it yet but I have another 50s
one
uh planned for this weekend but I'm not
gonna say what it is I think Padre you
was saying he see your other reviews
yeah okay yeah
um and I have a couple like book reviews
written out too because I've actually
read a couple of books and I got one
from an author that I just finished
today so I wrote a review of that and
then I have another one that's going
ahead of that so I have been like
reading a lot lately and I also
um Ben from Australia sent me a true
crime book like a non-fiction one and I
still got to read that too oh oh and
other day
you know how sometimes we say that we go
to koiwan the Chinese buffet yeah well
we found one that was slightly well we
found one that was a lot closer which
was okay it's like good in a pinch we
might go tomorrow yeah maybe I want some
shrimp that's only like eight miles from
our house yeah which isn't because
koiwan is like a half hour drive at
least maybe 40 minutes more like 40
minutes yeah now and it's still
relatively close it's just you got to
fight traffic and that's yeah it's just
a pain in the house yeah so
um so we found one that was like closer
what the [__] is the name of that place
that was like eight miles away and like
I said that place was all right it was
it was okay it wasn't as good as coil it
was kind of cold but it but it was like
okay like I said if you're desperate
yeah
um but there's also an Ichiban yeah
buffet that turned out being only about
like five ten miles closer than koiwan
but we're like well we'll try it out
just so we have some options so we went
there and that place was pretty nice too
it's actually like pretty big and they
had a lot of stuff but the one thing
that I was excited about is that where
it is is right across from a mall that
had a big books a million yeah and it's
a dead Mall basically but it's got the
bookstore and I was like and the
bookstore was pretty crowded yeah we
went in there had a coffee shop and
everything like it has it's books a
million so it has Joe mugs it doesn't
have Starbucks that's a Barnes Noble
thing but um so I was like oh bookstore
because I think I could be wrong about
this that might be the closest bookstore
to our house and then it's 18 miles bro
that's 18 miles from our house is the
closest bookstore I'm pretty sure yeah
so I was like okay [__] we are going in
there and like wandering around the
bookstore because I used to do that
every weekend and now I don't get to
because there's we need to check here
what the day time or what the daytime
prices on Ichiban are
yeah it wasn't that bad it was like 12
bucks wasn't it
14 bomb yeah I think it was 14 a person
or yeah 15 a person they had everything
they had everything that they would
normally have but it was packed it's
packed yeah holy [__] they had
everything they normally had at our
other place except they didn't have
steak
um but the shrap was still good one
thing that they had that
um that koiwan does not have is they had
egg foo young that's right that's right
and the Egg for young was actually
really good and I was like I want to
write koiwan doesn't have it they have
everything else because I love it yeah
but what I was gonna say is that we went
on uh books a million and
one thing okay I didn't spend money on
this because I wanted to they had
Trivial Pursuit but the horror Edition
and I was like oh man it was 50 and I
was like thinking about it but then I
was like well [__] I'd probably just
have to play with you and then I would
always win yeah so it wouldn't be any
fun no like I would kick your ass yeah
you would you wouldn't know [__] I
wouldn't know [__] right so it's like I
kind of want that maybe I can just like
play with myself
we gotta get you in a geeky little
girlfriends to come over to come over
and play horror and play horror board
games because I still haven't we because
remember you bought me that shining
board game and I really want to play
that even though it sounds super
complicated yeah
um but it's like we just never get
around you if you're a geeky goth
horror fan that wants to nerd out nerd
out with Jenny and play Trivial Pursuit
and shoot porn scenes we'll [__] just
come on over here we'll do it all Sonia
we'll have we'll put you on stream mate
and everything
yeah we're taking applications
but like I said you have to be like
super none of this fake like oh I like
gotta be nerdy you got to be like
[__] nerdy about this [__] I'm gonna
test you yeah Jenny likes nerdy girls
nerdy cute girls yeah I do yeah yeah
that's my thing yeah but yeah so
especially if you're like a horror nerd
yeah we can talk about it all night long
little round glasses and [__] if you're
little and cute Jenny loves you
Tom's just excited he's hoping that it's
for some girl on girl action I'm a man
that's how it goes we'll see how it goes
I mean we could we could recruit yeah
well then we agree there's one girl at
the club that just had her name written
all over her and she's like you go get
that one and that girl was sweet on me
but she wouldn't she goes she goes but
she comes back later like she turned it
down a week later she goes you must
understand something Mr Ross we did ask
her about yeah I am straight then she
says I am straight I said yeah of course
you're straight it doesn't mean anything
come hang out with us she wouldn't
I am a low-income person she said all
kinds of she says some cute [__] she
[__] says
I haven't seen her in a while now I
remember that girl's name she had this
crazy ass name that she has assumed name
that she uses it sounds like some kind
of Greek goddess I don't I can't
remember like that like come on that's
not your name what's your real name no
that is the name that you will call me
that's how she talks yeah yeah yeah
she's adorable
and then she had the goofiest boyfriend
she brought yeah
[__] was Goofy
I don't even remember that I remember
that guy I wasn't looking at I wasn't
looking at the dude but yeah so so not
only did they have the horror trivia but
they also had like all these end caps
with like all this really cool like
horror [__] they had like they had all
these like stuffed cthulhu's they had
like a whole Disney villain section they
had this adorable like little Maleficent
like
plushy thing and I was just like oh [__]
I really kind of want that and I'm like
oh my God I'm gonna spend a million
dollars in here now I did spend some
money this is what I got and I see this
like books a million and Barnes and
Noble this is why I used to go every
weekend because if you don't know like
in the front when they put a book out on
in um paperback then they sell off the
hardback like super cheap like all the
leftovers they have so you can get like
hardbacks for like six bucks man and
it's like super awesome that's why I
have like 40 bajillion books in here and
every time I move it's like a big pain
in the ass because they weigh a thousand
pounds but they had check this [__] out
this I think was six dollars Mammoth
book of Cthulhu and it's all like short
stories like lovecraftian stories and I
was like oh my God I gotta [__] have
that right so I got that and I also got
I was oh my God I was so excited about
this
I also got moonflower murders
by Anthony Horowitz now if you guys have
been watching my book reviews I did
um his earlier book which is called
Magpie murders and I loved that [__]
book it was like a um it's like an old
school whodunit like inside like a
modern whodunit like a turducken
um and it was like really really good
and I was like oh [__] man I gotta get
that second book and they had the
hardback
for six dollars I got this for six
[__] dollars so I'm gonna be
reviewing this at some point but I
haven't started reading it yet because I
had like I said I had an author that I
had reviewed one of his books before
like a British author and he sent me his
new one so I just finished reading that
yesterday and I did a review of it okay
we pretty much just ended hour one if
you guys could help us out go ahead and
hit that like button please we've got a
[__] ton of people in the comments
please like us please like and help me
and subscribe and share Al Pedro said
see you guys later gotta get my ass back
to work okay that's no fun all right but
good to have you back on bro and hit up
Jenny on Facebook and she'll send you
our address and uh yeah like I said I
need people just listening you're
listening recorded just uh find either
me or Jen on or [__] 13 o'clock on
Facebook or Instagram and uh ask for our
address and we'll send you the mailing
address here yeah like a million
different I have Jenny Ashford which is
my yeah right that's my personal account
I also have like a Jenny Ashford that's
like my author account I have a 13
o'clock account I have a scare Salon
account I have a crime and Memorial to
get out I have like so many [__]
accounts on there yeah and I can give
you the address too if you want to find
me but it's easier to find Jen I think
her footprint's bigger yeah I'm all over
the [__] yeah I'm all over the place it
probably is much easier and I have like
a slightly more Uncommon name yeah than
you have all right
uh John Robertson said hey Jenny I found
some artwork that is a Peter Cushing and
it's like tarot cards that represent the
roles he's played oh [__] like Van
Helsing Sherlock Holmes and Frankenstein
they're really oh my God what about
Grandma Tarkin oh my God please don't
tell me that because I might need to get
those
see this is what happens is like this is
why I used to spend so much money like
because I would go to like Barnes and
Noble and [__] like that like every
weekend and I was just like every time
they had like some creepy [__] or some
scary books or something I'd be like
yeah I gotta have that why do you think
this [__] office is so full of stuff
yeah because I just can't I can't resist
it
you know
but you know yes office is becoming a
museum
and then our little live our little damn
living room upstairs is starting to look
like a damn
um uh Studio I'm excited because there's
one out there well we weren't using that
room for anything no pretty much it's
like this because what it is this house
is big yeah it's big and it's like the
upstairs has it's almost like a living
room or like a den
like you can't supposed to be a den this
is where the kids are supposed to live
and the master bedroom is downstairs
and the kids are supposed to live up
here but we wanted to live up here yeah
and it does have this is actually like
the second master bedroom yeah that
we're in right now but we don't live in
this we use this as this one actually
this room might be bigger than the
bedroom we're using yeah it is because
this is the one that has the attached
bathroom yeah because there's like a
bathroom right through there like the
fan and everything and the other but see
when we first moved into the house and I
was like well I want one of these rooms
for the office but I told Tom it's like
which one do you want for the bedroom
because I don't really care I was like
this one's bigger and it has the
bathroom attached this made more sense
as an office in a studio but he wanted
the other one for the bedroom because it
had a high ceiling and this one doesn't
this just has like a regular yeah
ceiling the room that we're in is better
as a bedroom
yeah it doesn't have a ceiling fan
that's the only thing that's the only
thing wrong with it but it's like but I
bought a column fan yeah like that I
just put on the nightstand and that
works out pretty good that it's just
like Blues right because I can't stand
not having air blowing on me when I'm
sleeping it's hot in here Jenny likes a
[__] I do
laughs don't we all yeah don't we all
you do as well we're talking of course
uh Zach says why would a high ceiling
matter for a bedroom I don't I'm not
really sure I guess well because you
feel less claustrophobic I feel like
yeah he's liked it it felt more open
yeah like real open I don't like closed
in spaces like real and I don't like
houses filled with a bunch of
Furniture yeah he's kind of minimalist
yeah I like big Open Spaces that you can
walk through and I like things being
very functional
I don't like little [__] like Boomer
bling I [__] hate Boomer bling I hate
[__] uh
things that are like furniture for the
sake of being Furniture to fill an empty
space I don't like that
I like everything to look kind of like
an office or an industrial park or a
mall or something like that
I like everything to kind of have a
like a minimalist appearance to it I
don't know just part of having a
military bear it isn't like clutter I
don't like any kind of clutter I like
everything clean I like to clean a
vacuum a vacuum a lot and [__] a
clean well you kind of have to vacuum a
lot like between my hair and Pookie's
hair yeah there's probably like [__]
tumbleweeds like all in this [__]
house right and I [__] hated the
old-fashioned [__] 70s and 80s where
you had to walk in between all the
furniture and [__] and the [__] your
grandma's got a damn [__] dining room
and it's like place sittings for the
queen is coming over and all this
[__] dishes and stupid [__] that's
never used you know except maybe like on
Thanksgiving
you really don't even want to be there
for Thanksgiving and then they got all
the [__] [__] that they bought at
the Cracker Barrel because they went to
the Cracker Barrel in Pennsylvania or
some stupid [__] you know
people were funny back in the day so I
don't like any of that
I like the things to be kind of business
like
I I do like all of my all of my horror
shots no I like this I like this I like
this because our house looks like an
amusement park
galaxies on the ceilings and projections
Zach's seen it I've sent videos of Zach
to Zach and [__] with the bedroom
ceiling look like it's got a down
swirling Galaxy on the ceiling
yeah it's real hypnotic yeah so I like
lighting effects and empty spaces
lighting yeah pretty much the whole
upstairs like looks like nightclub
lighting like we have all these lasers
like we have in here like lasers like on
the ceilings and stuff yeah so it's just
kind of like but it's cool because what
we did with the big space like we didn't
have it painted it yet Tom painted the
bedroom like he painted like a dark blue
which is really pretty
but um I still haven't hung any artwork
up I needed to get around to that but um
what we did with the big open space like
all we had in there before was just the
mini fridge and like a little shelf
thing that had like some of our small
Debra's on it and like our ice machine
and that's pretty much it but now Tom
kind of like rearranged it all the other
day he made like a little snack area
that has like the little mini fridge and
like the shelving that has like snacks
on it and then a little table with
chairs and a little table with chairs
and then like in the other Corner we put
up like I bought
um like a rolling uh like what do they
call that like a clothes yeah I could
take a video of like a clothes hanger
thing and um so I put all my new clothes
on that like the stuff we use for the
shoots and everything like that and then
like I bought like this shelfing
shelving unit and I bought like all
these wig stands so I have like all the
wigs on because I have like a bunch of
wigs you guys so it's like so I have all
those on there and I bought like little
little drawers that have like all my
stocking things and like other little
[__] that I use like for the videos and
like you know just going out clothes and
stuff so I put all of that in there so
it looks really cool so now it's kind of
like a dressing room slash
snack bar and then we have like a couple
little chairs and tables in there so it
looks more like an actual room now
whereas before it just kind of looked
like a space that wasn't really being
utilized for anything you know because
like I said it's supposed to be
I guess the intention was it's supposed
to be like you know the kids would live
up here you know if a normal family
lived in the house
um the kids would live up here and
that's where their video games and [__]
like that this is what she's talking
about
oh you filmed it I just filmed it
that's the stairwells
and I'm going out into the yeah
[__] yeah see the ring light
there's the
little stack bar
colored lights and stuff so that's it
yeah
and it did the colors did not look
accurate I was watching them on the
screen yeah they're all purples and
blues so it's more like
that color
right there whoops
Jenny's boobs I was gonna say was that
boobs no yeah his boobs but you don't
see anything look look how cute Tom is
all of his all my little all of his
tablets he has two of them yeah have
pictures of me yeah on the back usually
they usually they have boobs in them
though well hey don't okay
I can't see anything yeah you could
can't see nothing yeah you could yeah
and he changes him out like all the time
because when you do pictures come I'll
change them out well because we do you
know shoots every weekend with different
outfits and stuff like that so he always
goes through and I upload everything to
Dropbox and then he goes through there
and picks out his favorite ones and then
puts them yeah it's like and we're uh
just getting
um fully approved for streaming all I
have to do is upload
something that has like proof of address
so I have to like upload like a bill or
something like that and then that's all
I have to do which I gotta find out
where that is
I could probably I could probably like
find a credit card statement or some
[__] like that it's pictures of Jan
oh he's gonna show like yeah I'm gonna
show the the the just the R rated ones
no X-rays I was gonna say because yeah
we're gonna get well we're probably
already gonna get demonetized
um I'm gonna do the ones with the blonde
hair that you did
but there's a lot of those blonde hair
what do you mean like white white hair
oh white hair yeah
I don't love the white wig jamming white
hair but I mean that's a good picture
though it's a great picture oh man I'm
getting
that came out good yep
and I think did I have the Green contact
lenses in yeah were those were those the
green ones
because Tom bought me blue contact
lenses and Green contact lenses yeah
so I was trying I was trying out
different eye colors because my eyes are
dark brown in case you never noticed but
yeah they're green in that one
yeah that came out yeah like I said this
picture no you look beautiful
the white wig isn't my favorite but
you got a top on no I don't yeah there
was top there oh well that's what I do
yeah
that one I do yeah
you can't tell him anything no of course
not I do what I wanted
they can't see anything he doesn't care
if I get to monetizer
all of my [__] gets divided the the
there wasn't enough oh look how cute
this is
that was my that's my mom wig yeah is
this my Gothic mom
goth mom comes in and does something
naughty to you that was that was also I
had blue contact yeah yeah
because he was like freaked out by that
because he's like oh my God you look
completely different yeah you look
completely like when I have blue eyes
yeah okay here maybe I'll maybe I'll do
the blue eyes tomorrow okay I don't know
jamming blue eyes yeah there we go she
looks totally different
and that's my cool like black and white
wig too yeah like with the little Grace
yeah I like that wig I got that on GN
too
also we got not only did we get the new
shipment of tops today which like a [__]
ton but the other day got a couple
dildos
yeah
you want to show them don't do that like
I said to monetize but yeah like well
we've been looking like she and has some
of that stuff too
so I was like I like I said I like ones
that are like the look good on camera I
don't really like realistic looking ones
because they're boring and kind of like
bizarre like and growth but um I like
ones that are like
weird looking or
hat or like cool colors or something
like that so I got one that was kind of
like pink and purple like gradient and
then we did get one that was kind of
like realistic looking but we got one
because it was like um
because it uh how it has like a what's a
tactful way to put this I don't think
there's a tackle way to put this what's
that it squirts oh yeah
no and they didn't really have any cool
looking ones not that I could find that
um that did that no the real expense the
the real good looking ones actually in
the cool looking ones are expensive they
are yeah they got a lot of Studios out
there [__] custom making these steaks
and um you're gonna look at between a 7
70 and 150 bucks
for those things yeah uh but you see
that
for what me and Jen are doing they
basically
how they feel doesn't [__] matter
what it is is it how how cool they look
on camera yeah we just want them to look
cool they have to look cool because I
have to say some of the ones that we
have that look cool on camera
um they're [__] crazy
not real uh let's put it this way not
real pleasurable you know what I mean to
use them in the way that they were
intended yeah but they look really cool
yeah they're pink or they're [__]
purple and black and we got a couple
likes we got a couple monster ones yeah
it's all monsters and animals one that's
like blue and purple and it's got like
all these it looks kind of like um
Cthulhu you could probably show that
though what was that one have we shown
that weird green one that we got the
other day that looks kind of like yeah
that's Dragon shape yeah all right
that's some weird [__] yeah I like the
way it looks though it's cool and then
there's like some [__] Martian yeah
oh and that glows in the dark too yeah
which I didn't actually realize until we
were filming in a dark room and I was
like oh look at that
okay they're asking questions and stuff
uh did Tom ever see the screenshots oh
yeah I have been I forgot all about it
should have reminded me or gone there
and read it he's having problems with
his boyfriend he wanted me to
psychoanalyze the boyfriend yeah exact
room it's his ex-boyfriend though yeah
who's stalking him and [__] with him
out of the blue years after the fact
I have to read it man that's bizarre I
mean I'm I'm a man just like you I
should be able to back engineer it but
I'm not gay like you see the gay Factor
might have something maybe I can but
maybe maybe I can see something you
won't be able to see because I'm I'm
just dispassionate I'm not I'm not
emotionally believe the idea of I'm not
emotionally involved so I could say okay
I know what he's saying but usually
if you dump somebody and then a years
later they come and come back and start
[__] with you it's because they're
heartbroken over you well it's got to be
because why otherwise
I mean how who does that like your
breakup breaks up with somebody and then
like five six years down the line like
usually you're not even like you yeah
yeah you're not even like thinking about
that if you're normal you're not even
like thinking about that person anymore
so it's just kind of like if you're
still obsessing about that person then
there's obviously some issues going on
because honestly like
I don't even remember [__] that happened
that long ago to be honest with you I
mean me and Tom have been together a
long time but I'm just saying like prior
to that like [__] we've been together
12 years 12 years I've known him longer
than that but we've actually kind of
I've known him about a year and a half
longer than that so I've known probably
about like 13 and a half years but I
think we've been together together for
12 years I think it'll be 12 years this
summer which is crazy that's
that's almost as long as I was married
previously
because I don't know if you guys know
but I was married for 14 years
all right because I'm old I'm old as
[__] I'm very pretty young I was 22.
um
Tyler the guy said I have this joke I
tell where I pitch a concept similar to
Build a Bear Workshop but it's for
dildos yeah it's like that kind of
sounds like a joke but they don't I
don't know if they have like an actual
build a dildo dildo
um Workshop that's what they should call
it if it's not called that but um they
do have I mean you can get custom ones
and it's like I didn't really know that
either like you know I'm not I used to
have an Amazon store where I sell sex
toys and stuff but I didn't make them or
nothing it's like I was always like just
reselling ones that already were
available
but once we like started getting into
um you know thinking about doing videos
and streaming and stuff like that and we
started like looking into the [__] and
like what some of the other performers
had and stuff like that I'm like holy
[__] they have like all this it's a
whole subculture man they have like a
whole
um they have all these [__] crazy
ones like I said I'm into
not you know not for the functionality
but just like the way they look I'm
really into like all the whole sub-genre
of like monster ones so they have ones
that are kind of like Cthulhu as they
have ones that look like tentacles and
they have ones that I'm just like
they're really cool looking like I said
they're not super Pleasant to use but um
but they look really cool and also they
have a whole
um and like I said we've probably
already been demonetized so it's fine
but they but they have a whole thing
they can't really say it
um because of laws but um they have ones
that look like
um various animal
um penises
let's let's put it that way well they
get around with them because they change
certain things and they call it like a
werewolf this and right but it's clearly
like it's like a red rocket yeah it's a
red rock is what it is somebody's asking
um
and there's big money in that [__] uh
the kinkier that [__] is on stream mate
doing the live streams the more
the more interest you're gonna get
because it you can't go with the same
old same old and our stream mate show is
gonna have a lot of humor in it we're
gonna be drinking we're gonna be [__]
around just like we're doing right now
just that of course the clientele is a
little bit different y'all are invited
when the [__] goes down we're gonna have
the Lakes
so you guys can come visit if you show
up over there
you can tip
gonna be titty flashes or just whatever
you know what I mean we can do gold
shows
depends on [__] how Juiced up we are
at the time there's no way to [__]
tell what could happen anything could
happen but it could definitely be an
x-rated show
and we could we can say a lot more over
there
too yeah over here I'm always trying to
be like okay watch it right although
like I said I'm at this point I'm just
kind of like well it's probably 90 is
going to be demonetized anyway so it's
like after a certain point I'm like ah
whatever [__] it especially like on the
Friday Night Show because
I feel like nobody that isn't like a
super fan of the show is going to be
watching these anyway so I'm not like
super worried about it right I'm more
worried about it like on the Regular
Show in the video reviews and stuff
because I feel like people that don't
that aren't fans of the show might
stumble across this but this one I don't
think they would
um over here there's a lot of censorship
and like I said demonetization now it's
something guys can understand the stream
mate show has two modes the public mode
and on public you can only go R-rated
you can show you top nudity that's about
it that's all right so you can't show
below the belt right you're right that's
our original like that's in their
contract like no x-rated in public
so anything that X-rated has to happen
in private so there's like private shows
or private one-on-ones
um it you we can go cam to cam but that
costs more money most dudes don't want
that they just want to quit private I
don't know if I'm comfortable yeah to be
honest I might not put that as an option
right because you don't have to right
like I don't know if I necessarily want
to see them but uh we'll be selling
videos on there and photos yeah we got a
bunch of photos yeah we got a lot of
videos hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of photos and about a dozen
videos at least yeah like I gotta edit
some of them still but it's like we do
have like a lot because we do Clips like
every weekend yeah the videos will be
about a dollar a minute so a 15 minute
videos about 15 bucks okay five minutes
about five minutes some of them real
quick
and there's gonna be a lot of free stuff
too
yeah we're gonna do we're like we've
already started doing stuff that's like
not as explicit yeah that's gonna be
like free or like available for Samplers
or teasers or whatever and then like the
other stuff is gonna be like yeah behind
a page and I've tested it out on some
dudes [__]
like I've said it's fine like I don't
really care like I think he thinks that
I'm being shy about it but I'm just kind
of like curious because he today he was
like oh I sent
I sent like samples to all these other
people and they said this and that I'm
like who'd you send it to I was just
like Curious friends friends of the show
and uh a few Club friends
that's all because I'm not I wouldn't
I'm not worried or I wouldn't be doing
it these Nest has seen uh samples
some of it was post-production but good
post production before editing and he's
like yeah yeah it's gonna be good
[__] yeah no we we're having a good
time dude we made good [__] yeah
and uh people's like well you gotta a
few weeks back oh man my Zach was like
my favorite people are becoming porn
stars were not porn stars we don't work
for a studio we don't have to [__] 100
people 200 people a year like you do if
you don't [__] Studio it's just me
and Jen like I said I don't want to do
it it's just me and Jen it's just me and
Jen yeah we're practically married we've
been together 13 [__] years yeah okay
so and and and the videos is good it's
fun and we cut up during it there's
there's humor in it and Jenny added some
[__] funny [__] that I say
[__] funny looks on my faces and [__]
on one photo but then some of the other
stuff is just kind of like basic stuff
that dudes like we know what's popular
yeah like you said I mean Tom is kind of
like a porn connoisseur I know guys in
the industry I [__] confer with them
so asking like what's gonna say yeah
like what sells what doesn't sell mostly
although I was gonna say when I was
talking about the um the animal penises
yeah we watched one was I don't remember
if it was streamate or ChatterBait or I
don't remember what it was
but remember that woman she was a
British woman and her whole thing was
yeah uh horse horses and dogs dildos
yeah
oh [__] come on
too explicit well I don't know it says
it might be the storm yeah storm it
reconnected okay it's back it's
reconnected I think it reconnected yeah
I think it's bad it's going to drop
something in the damn comment section
it's storming here so I don't know so I
don't know it's like
the name of the video is what your mom's
been up to at the stable right yeah
that's right and you walk in on her
yeah which uh whoops yeah what's your
mom about doing she's a British chick
she's in her late 20s yeah it's all
fantasy she's just talking [__] and uh
pretending to blow these [__] big old
[__] horses and [__] funny
and there's some of them have a lot some
of those girls that do that [__] have a
[__] big sense of humor
they'll use [__] big old [__]
human stuff and they're like look I
don't have the rent but I have a mouth
that was that [__] was [__] I was
rolling I like that girl yeah she's
funny I can't with like kind of this
[__] hit kind of slightly overweight
cute but overweight chick food it's just
her in her apartment with all these
dildos and Camera yeah and she's just
trying to make content and she's got a
great imagination and she'll tell all
kinds of stories to the camera and
she's taking you on a journey she's in
trouble she's like and yeah she's in
trouble she's got and it's super funny
and she'll cry and like her mascara is
running yeah and then like a dildo be
like hitting in her face like some dude
is like hitting her like faces yeah oh
my God it's so funny it's hilarious I
like her she's she's like super some
people I don't know some people who are
kind of vanilla might be upset about the
oh that's terrible no it's funny it's
funny as [__] because these are these
are just people trying to make products
to sell and they're trying to get your
girls trying to make some money yeah and
and they're trying to entertain you sure
and and it's all made up fans no one's
making them do it yeah and if they want
to do it yeah and they're telling you a
story you know to uh to get you off
right it's a service yeah and um we made
it you know what I mean it's fun to make
yeah it's fun to bake it's I mean it's
hot it's hard work yeah and it's not
normal sex and it's not as you know it's
not as fun as just like doing it would
not be filmed but it's because you have
to like worry about a bunch of other
people yeah like other like afterwards
running I hope the [__] microphone
picked that up it's that kind of [__]
you know right it's like wait is this
yeah are we singing what right like it
looks cool from this angle but not from
this angle and you can't just go for it
because you're doing it in takes yeah
and it's it's pieced together afterwards
so it's it's not normal but you're kind
of constantly on the edge you kind of
kind of keep yourself on the edge of it
if you don't talk about edging well yeah
because what we've been doing like since
we've started doing this is like so
pretty much every Saturday like every
Saturday afternoon like after we do
whatever we need to do
um you know as far as errands and like
going grocery shopping and [__] like
that then I'll kind of like do all my
makeup and we'll pick out some outfits
and [__] like that and then we'll just
spend like the whole afternoon [__]
around just filming stuff doing photos
and like doing video clips and doing
[__] like that so it's like we'll do it
for like five or six hours like have a
drink or two yeah and just like yeah you
know guess wild you guys would like it
yeah it's like you know it's actually
it's actually really fun you gotta dress
up and you gotta have wild sex and it
can't be real sex It's gotta be some
flamboyant and it's got to come up with
these [__] crazy ideas
and
most and it's not for you it's for the
camera
yes so it's very different I mean it's
still enjoyable I'm not saying that but
it's like you do have to keep it in the
back of your mind all the time like how
it's looking for the camera like how is
it gonna look for like the end user and
as a guy it's rough
because this shit's gonna go off for
hours yeah all right
and you can't reach climax or you're
gonna lose [__] interest yeah because
you're gonna be like yeah I'm gonna go
take a nap yeah so you gotta [__]
remain on the edge and and interested
for hours
I'm [__] almost 54 okay even with all
the [__] hormonal assistance and [__]
it's
I got stamina better than any [__] 15
year old you're doing a good job yeah I
got more my stamina is better than 15
years I'm gonna sit over there because
I'll sit over there wired tight because
I do a lot of like solo [__] like I'll
do like a lot of I said at my phone like
in the ring lane and then he'll record
like other angles and stuff like that
I'm doing like photos and yeah you know
and video shoots and stuff like that and
he's just like he's really into it yeah
no lying what she's doing is [__]
sending me to the roof but I can't
really
it evolved see because uh sometimes he
can't take it I gotta get some of this
it's all start and I've even recorded
that it'll only be like [__] 20
seconds and then jump back off okay okay
we gotta get back to work
it is funny behind the scenes a lot of
the [__] that we do it's very funny and
uh so okay we gotta get this site and
I'm running like two or three different
cameras or on poles and [__]
yeah I'll have one I'm on a truck
because I record [__] on my phone and
then he records [__] like on the on the
action cam you need three different
angles happening and then we kind of
synthesize it into a video so there's
[__] angle changes and Camera changes
and certain things will happen One
camera can't pick that up the other
camera's got to see that
and it's
it is an art form I remember people
saying oh that's not work
[__] I have a background in theater
too
it is work yeah it's a weird kind of
work
uh but no it's what you're producing a
product that you're trying to sell and
you're trying to tell a story and it's
got to be entertaining and it has to be
sexual and [__] well it has to look
good you have to like worry about all
the technology what's what's natural for
a woman is not necessarily what a guy is
looking for in watching this video
that's the main customer so sometimes
there's a guy I gotta go oh yeah you
know what there's not a cool down period
that dude hit climax when you did that
now you need another 30 seconds or a
minute of [__] kind of cooling down
because he's going to be looking at you
yeah because it's like like if I get
into it and it's just like if I get into
it right then it's just like I'm not
thinking about like that like I said the
end user and so Tom's gonna be like well
you have to like understand that this is
the dude that watching you and he's
gonna want like this many more seconds
yeah and he's sitting there [__]
and because well after a guy of course
it reaches climax you know his
endorphins are what do they call is
[__] going through his body and he's
almost kind of like under a slight
heroin trip he's [__] relaxing and
he's a zoning out oh man
so you got to give him time to [__]
unwind yeah which is kind of like
sometimes I forget like especially if I
get like really into it yeah it's like I
just forgot about it because I just get
because once I once it's all wrapped up
in my own she's seen me do it she's oh
yeah of course that's what you guys do
yeah but like I said I get wrapped up in
my own shape yeah it's just like kind of
[__] and I just forget that's all
because I'm not I mean
yeah two different systems and the thing
about it too is that
I don't know it's weird because I feel
like I adapted a lot quicker to
doing this [__] on camera than I thought
I would
you know what I mean like I thought it
would be weird and unnatural and stuff
but it's just kind of like I was like
okay whatever
Zach goes [__] you're back the boob
detector said no
yeah horse dildos broke the internet I
guess as soon as we said yeah I might
break the internet although like I said
it is storming outside so we did the
storm yeah it is you would not believe
how much those sucking things cost
yeah well the lady that we saw she had
two of them but she probably has more
than that the video that that we saw but
she had one on each side yeah and she's
like yeah pretending that she's out in
the stable she's just in her room you
know what I mean it's not imagination it
doesn't even look like the stable no
she's talking you into this right into
this [__] kinky ass and like I said
the whole scenario was that her son
walked in walked into disabled and saw
mom and saw her blowing and then she's
got to justify it and then she's like
you know you like this
[__] we'll like you like I said the
think about it I don't know if it's son
or stepson
something like that but I said well
that's what we were saying is like I
kind of feel like the the best [__] or
the peop the the [__] that people tend
to respond to the best is stuff that's
like a little bit I mean obviously it's
not real she's not really blowing horses
or anything like that but um it's stuff
that's like transgressive like stuff
that you're not supposed to do because
that whole like [__] right
that that whole like taboo thing is like
what is getting people off on it even if
it's fake right which all of it is but
it can't violate loss so you know what I
mean [__] right everybody has to be
above 18. and even in the story you
don't even want to tell and you don't
want to [__] promote any of that
[__] real [__] kinky [__] anyway
it's just this is all uh tongue-in-cheek
yeah she's not doing anything to horses
this is [__] Robert dicks
and they're clearly they're clearly yeah
yeah and she's clearly not a staple yeah
she's just in her room he's like in a
room in her house yeah
but she's good at talking though yeah
it's talking it's like a whole scenario
this is something as a guy
um who kind of grew up and [__]
looking at this [__] like a lot of you
guys did
really the women that [__] would
knock it out of the park for me really
didn't have a lot to do with how they
looked is what they said
if a woman had [__] mouth game and it
could talk man that would [__] really
affect you because
sensuality is so psychological
there's a visual aspect to men that are
highly visual
but when you really get down to it it's
psychological and uh
unfortunately
most women don't have any game
uh even really pretty women don't have
any game at all if they were dudes they
couldn't get laid
they just happen to be pretty women so
they're getting laid all the time and
[__] guy go oh yeah yeah yeah but if
that was but if you moved her into a
dude's body that girl wouldn't be able
to get laid in a Mexican whorehouse okay
she says no [__] game at all they
don't know how to talk
and
um they can't [__] elicit [__]
emotion out of some [__] dude with a
store now some women can
okay it's PR it takes practice and I've
noticed that real pretty girls never
have to rely on that they just have
their looks right so they now never end
up having any game
well we've said that before and it's
like I don't really like to make blanket
statements like that but you do see it a
lot with like really really beautiful
women like really yeah that were really
pretty girls because they were so pretty
they didn't usually have to work real
hard at [__] yeah so it's like a lot of
times they didn't really have to have
other skills I guess like they didn't
have to be smart or they didn't have to
be socially Adept or they didn't have to
be anything like that because they were
pretty so they always got everything
like given to them so they didn't have
to like work really hard otherwise and
that's not true across the board yeah
because we know many many many
super like ridiculously beautiful girls
that are also awesome yeah people yeah
real good quality people and moral and
friendly and friendly to everybody and
not snotty and they're just yeah
gorgeous so it's so that's the thing so
I kind of feel like some people is like
oh like the hotter a girl is like the
snotty or she is that is absolutely not
the case that is absolutely not the case
no because we know lots of like like I
said just ridiculously beautiful it
depends on the scene that urges I think
yeah that are just like the most awesome
people I call this into some of this
[__] uh manosphere red pill stuff and
this is always mostly from guys in their
20s in the 20s perspective oh man it
better there better looking The Other
Board [__] [__] there no they're not
no because I like to listen to what guys
are saying there is a lot of Truth in
what they're saying but they have to
understand that they're seeing it from a
temporary perspective of a guy in his
20s you know I mean with the problems of
a guide is twice man the 20s is [__]
shitty for dudes because you can't
compete with the guys in their 30s
all the girls you're going for when
you're in your 20s or other women in
their 20s the guys in the 30s are
getting them all because they got the
money and women well money stability
money stability better personality than
you yeah less likely to [__] around yeah
you're like do dumb [__] when you when
you're a guy in your 20s you just don't
have that much to offer to a woman in
their 20s you got a lot to offer to a
girl some girl [__] coming out of
high school but you don't want that
because she can't drink she can't come
to the club with you and your friends
would all laugh at you if you ended up
with an 18 17 year old girl
so if you're in your 20s man you're
[__] that's the time you join the Army
or [__] joint get into a [__]
motorcycle gang or do some prison time
or something well at least have a
[__] Advantage at least work on
yourself yeah work on yourself go live
don't worry about girls go work out on
go go work out and go on to some [__]
oil rig or something make a bunch of
money or something you know [__] but
dominating the [__] women scene
that's not gonna happen for you in your
20s as a guy that's the time you should
be out having an adventure with other
dudes well become an interesting better
person yeah and then you will get
quality ladies later on yeah or quality
dudes I did pretty well in my 20s but
nowhere near what I could do in my 30s
it's hard in your 20s the competition is
too tough
you don't offer enough
yeah well like I said a lot of dudes in
their 20s are just are they're just kind
of figuring [__] out they don't have any
money they don't have any stability they
still kind of they'll still cheat on you
they'll do this you'll get a date with
just some hot chick you might be able to
hit it once but she's not coming back
she just wanted to sex
she really wants to do it in her 30s
that has the stability
yeah just didn't have anything else to
do and you were hot enough to [__] but
she didn't take you seriously yeah
because women will totally do that yeah
they'll just like if they see a dude
they like they're like yeah I'll [__]
that dude but they're not gonna like
hang around or nothing like women will
do that too like I kind of feel like
that's
um like it's not really my thing but I
know a lot I have done it I'm not saying
I haven't done that uh because I have
but
I'm just saying that I kind of feel like
the perception is that that's mostly a
dude thing that they'll just like hit it
and quit it but women will absolutely do
that too
it's not as common I don't think but
I've known lots of people that did that
I've done it myself it's like I said
it's not really my thing but you know
what I mean
John Robertson said hey Jenny I can send
you that artwork if you'd like oh my God
would you really that would be [__]
awesome if you would do that because
that sounds like amazing like the best
thing ever also Tom I finally got the
last piece of my black cat Halloween
costume a double-breasted robe was the
hardest thing to find I'll tell him when
he comes back but um but yeah
Camp guy said every man uh thinks of
themselves as the maximum viral sex
demon they do
um yeah and like I said I don't like to
make blanket statements like this but a
lot of dudes no matter what they look
like
no matter what they have to offer
otherwise personality wise whatever it
is
um they all seem to kind of think
they're God's Gift which
I always thought was kind of interesting
well because well like I said generally
women are the complete opposite like
we're just kind of like we always think
even the most look I you know some of my
friends are just like stupidly gorgeous
like stupid gorgeous
even they who I just think oh my God I
wish I [__] look like that she's like
ridiculous like I hate her she's like
beautiful who's this but no I'm just
saying that it's like but even the most
beautiful girls are like totally totally
insecure and they always think it's like
there's always someone prettier than me
there's always some skinnier than me
there's like I'm fat I'm like this and
that and the other women are really
really down on themselves a lot of women
right and honestly if you see a woman
that's like seems like super confident
and [__] like that she has also done
herself with like we all are and it's
shitty but that's just kind of how we
roll yeah Camp guys go on what I'm
saying is so true he likes to be teased
verbally yeah most women don't have any
game
uh the women that do have game a lot of
it is mouth game they can just [__]
talk it out of you and [__] you love
it I mean the first one that I really
ran into that had some mouth game was my
ex-girlfriend [__] Steph Stephanie
that was about 96 when I got out of the
army and she was just kind of an average
looking a little bit above average
looking goth girl but she could [__]
talk
all right and she was sexy but you also
couldn't trust her
that was nothing you couldn't trust her
and then but you're in your 20s and you
know what I mean and that's just the way
women are in their 20s you know uh
they're gonna go for the bigger better
deal which he eventually kind of did
over time she tried to play one dude off
the other and I was living with her
uh just kind of ran ran out quick you
know what I mean like burned it up quick
but she could [__] talk man
that was like the first girl that I ever
got that ever got a hold of me that
[__] and you know what I mean I had a
past in high school and [__] that was
the first one that [__] could just
[__] your mind up with what she said it
was just kinky [__] you know she should
have been a porn star she probably
weighs 400 pounds now though who knows
but she should have been a [__] porn
star
I should get my head turned it sideways
but like what you want me to what that
[__] off
man I tell you should I want you to do
and you won't do it well no she
said with you talking about tagging a
[__] but you know the you know
the uh you know the the girl with the
[__]
rubber horse dicks and she was like at
that level right she'd tell you all
kinds of crazy [__] she's making it up
though she just knew how to she just
knew how to
[__] with your mind
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah then she would
play all kinds of biology games about
how she was gonna have my baby and weird
[__] so it was like oh yeah I've known
she was into all that you know what I
mean yeah I never pulled that on a dude
I thought that was like a little too
weird oh she was [__] weird as [__] I
thought well here's the thing
um I thought about that [__] yeah I
think a lot of women do but it's like a
lot of times we're like should I say
that out loud probably not oh no she's
like put that baby right in there and
they're like what baby she says oh yeah
okay baby games I have said some [__]
like and just not to you but I have
something yeah she's just a baby [__]
[__] and I'm like what yeah I guess I
never really got too into that because
it's like I knew that I was faking but
because like I don't know I don't want
any babies yeah she's taking too she's
like a baby it's just anything and then
I was like I didn't want to do to get
the wrong idea I'm like please don't get
me pregnant oh my God yeah yeah I really
don't want that to happen yeah yeah she
didn't want that I'm not I'm not into
kids I knew who she I knew how she was
she wasn't she was she wasn't into that
either she was just knew how to [__]
[__] your mind up
see I always thought because like I said
I've thought about that kind of [__] it
was like should I say that out loud and
then I'm just like maybe I shouldn't
because it's like the dude are probably
like see this is the funniest boner I
would think now this is the funny thing
man
Jenny's probably like the the the the
most I would say like left chick I was
ever like really messed with but she's
in a weird way the most conservative the
most cautious [__] a lot of these
other women are freaking wild that I was
with they would say all kinds of [__]
crazy [__] and um no no dudes roll with
it we understand it we understand well
see that's the thing like I don't think
I'm not different because like I think
all that [__] yeah it's a lot a lot of
times I don't say it out loud right yeah
most people do Jen because I'm like if I
say it out loud then
um then like like I said he might lose a
boner or he might think of a weirdo or
something like that you're worried too
much well yeah that's kind of my thing
no but like so I'm not saying I don't
think that kind of [__] I do I just a
lot of times I just don't say it out I
was your ex-husband to [__] put that
in your head probably yeah probably
no [__] uh dudes really don't take
seriously what you say when sex is
happening they know you're just [__]
with them
[Laughter]
in a moment I guess I just like I said I
don't want to be responsible for like a
dude getting Susan is better than he
gets mad at me no you know what I mean
like I [__] it was like it was my
fault no no no chances are [__] you'd
Rock it'd Rock up even harder
listen listen to listen how women think
about to it just it's not
they some women not all of them but some
women overanalyzed too much oh well
he'll do this and that but men are not
women
we don't react the way women yeah I know
it's all over analyzed and we understand
like we understand games a lot more than
women do but see that's the thing though
is that that's the hell of it is that
I'm an over analyzing [__] and I
know because I'm an overanalyzing
[__] I know that dudes don't
over analyze but that makes me over
analyze even more yeah no I understand I
I know I totally understand do you know
what I'm saying yeah I know I know so
it's like I can't win
no yeah you can't just [__] it I know
well you're given too much of a [__]
well see that's why I kind of feel like
because we've talked about this lately
like ever since we've started like um
yeah you know doing the the filming and
everything like that I said it's taken
me this long like to this age in my life
before I just finally said [__] it [__]
it I don't give a [__] anymore yeah I
don't understand because like yeah I've
spent like so many years just like
worrying about [__] that probably I
shouldn't have worried about yeah I mean
but like I said that was kind of the
hell of it is that when you're when
you're an over analytical person like I
am when you're a Spock [__] yeah
she's [__] yeah like my ex-husband used
to call me that too so it's not just you
but um I know I'm like that but it's so
it's okay I'm not apologizing for it
it's like I I wouldn't want to be any
different even though it makes my life a
lot more difficult but the more like you
over analyze stuff but the fact that you
know that you're over analyzing it it's
like it makes it even worse because now
it's kind of like you know what I mean
because now you're just kind of like
it's another level of like over
analyzing yeah because you know that
they're doing it's like well [__] let me
get something straight with the audience
though
I've been around the block all right
my body counts a lot higher than Gents
all right
Jan [__] sells herself short Jen's
[__] amazing okay oh she yeah Jed's
amazing she's got
she doesn't do a lot of [__] that a lot
of [__] up women do all right one of
the reasons me and her were friends
before we started becoming an item
but over time I was like this doesn't
make sense not to go out with this chick
okay
because a lot of the [__] problematic
things that most women do she didn't do
it
she's real reasonable that's hard to
find with most women are not reasonable
uh real uh analytical she's kind of dude
like in a certain way where you can like
reason with her and a lot of women you
couldn't read with reason with or I
couldn't
um
so don't take it like
Jen's a [__] up no Jen's awesome she's
[__] uh I am kind of a [__] yeah
she's a great business partner
uh super reliable
real trustworthy uh Heart of Gold she's
a good woman
um
cells are sells herself short on a lot
of stuff she didn't quite have all the
opportunities in life that I had I
[__] was kind of born with [__] in
a good position and [__] had a lot of
[__] fun you know I did not and she
didn't really come up that way
uh
but still she thrived
you know
she thrived because I'm [__] stubborn
yeah she's very [__] stubborn and
it's you know why because I'm spiteful
yeah and that's another thing over the
years people have kind of like looked at
The Superficial dynamic between her and
me and thought that maybe I was some
kind of bully [__] uh [__]
dominating her or something you don't
understand what goes on in this [__]
house you know we're both very dominant
personalities all right uh and we're
both [__] strong and very dominant I
am quietly dominated yeah
okay but what's weird is normally that
would cause a lot of conflicts and a lot
of fighting but not between us we've
only had very few fights
and the fights that we had were [__]
we were drunk most of the time
I think all like almost 99 of the fights
you've ever had and then when we sobered
up we were just like what the [__] was
that all about I don't even remember
like we'll be driving she'd be hitting
me on hits
and then she'd throw up
oh come on it wasn't that bad
one time it was like that oh yeah I
already know what we were fighting I did
I don't remember anything I do remember
throwing up on the side of the car one
time like out the window because you
were like put your head out the window
but you're just like okay
and then the next day yeah I went out
there and there was like the throat was
all of a sudden and it was red yeah and
I was just like holy [__] I was throwing
up blood and you were like you [__]
you were drinking yeah cranberry
cranberry juice and vodka camera vodka
yeah so yeah cranberry juice you weren't
throwing up blood calm down that was a
long time ago that was like many years
ago but yeah well I mean we've known
each other for such a long time for 15
years that it's like yeah that like we
know each other's deal at this point so
it's like even if we like kind of sniped
each other and [__] like that
um
it's we're just kind of like whatever
you know what I mean because it's like
because I'm gonna get cranky he's gonna
get cranky it's just kind of like we're
just like whatever we just kind of let
it yeah but that's you know if it was
gonna blow up it would have blown up a
long time ago yeah I feel like it
probably
I feel like you probably would have but
it's like well that's what's weird it's
just I do kind of feel like maybe less
so nowadays because I kind of feel like
people know us better now because we've
been together such a long time but when
we first started going out or when we
first started hanging out together there
was kind of a thing
most people were for it because they're
like would you guys please because we
had hung out yeah people that knew us
were like why don't you guys go out yeah
it's like would you guys please just go
out already I mean obviously like you
know because like I said we we hung out
together all the time like and we
weren't officially together like he was
still like banging some other chick I
was still banging some other dude like
like some other [__] was going on and
but we would go out together all the
time we're gonna make money and yeah and
[__] like that and people were like
would you guys please just it's like
this is pissing us off like please just
go out already so so finally we're like
yeah I guess so so we did
but then for a while I think there were
people that didn't know us that that
maybe didn't know us as well that there
were also haters well that too but I
think yeah I think they thought that you
were
um bullying me or like controlling me or
something like that I mean you are kind
of like a very like I said you are a
very dominant person you are a very
controlling person but it's like I'm not
um like I said I'm not quite as getting
into like people's faces and stuff like
that but I'm absolutely just as like
dominating as you are just in a
different she was a lot more covert
yeah I'm like I'm like on yeah I'm like
dude I do it like sneaky way because me
and her be plotting about [__]
yeah you saw that [__] yeah so
we yeah we're gonna take this [__] yeah
so we were plotting together on certain
missions that we were gonna do but
people didn't know
yeah yeah I mean we were kind of we are
a power couple
we've done a lot of [__] at the scenes
for for years and years all the DJs and
everything we know and yeah we're a
power couple but they didn't really
understand back in those days what what
we were doing what our deal was yeah
yeah they were
looking at it from very superficial
point of view not really knowing who we
were
and what was going on behind the scenes
they were judging us by their standards
okay and those people are gone now hold
on
Camp guy said we got some kids books
when our kids were little
they had all kinds of cartoons of men
and women making babies can't remember
the name I kind of remember the one that
you're talking about I don't think I saw
that when I was little but I think I saw
them a little bit later
like making babies like the actual way
or making babies out of like clay
because how [__] funny
it's just
making babies and it's like as a man and
woman like sculpting a baby out of clay
like Zeus comes and like brings it to
life or whatever
now I kind of want to write that
children's book
um yeah so John Robertson said I can
send it to you by email or your Facebook
if you like I found it online make great
posters they are fantastic
um okay so my email I have two emails
well I actually have more than that but
the easiest one is grave cake at
gmail.com so if you want to send me the
stuff that would be really awesome there
you go thank you yeah it's Friday night
man yeah yeah we're getting crunk Friday
we're getting crunk up in this [__] and
it's almost five it's almost ten o'clock
that's okay I don't have to go it's been
two hours ago I don't have anywhere to
go tonight all right I'm gonna go ahead
and pass the collection play it around
if y'all want to buy me and Jada Drake
go ahead and [__] drop it in the
[__] comment section maybe not like
we need any more yeah we can have all
kinds of drinks we'll drink it we'll
drink it next week
yeah I mean you know it all works out
there's all kinds of comp people are
asking us questions go ahead and read
the questions off where are we seeing
down at the bottom I just see people
talking about us uh my glasses on I just
see our names popping up that was well
John Robertson is talking about those um
Peter Cushing pictures oh he's gonna
email them to me okay
um and then you might have already
answered this because I already said
like this Camp guy thing every every man
thinking of themselves I kind of want
you to weigh in on this okay every man
thinks of themselves as the maximum
viral sex demon yeah and I and I was
saying I think you were in the bathroom
or whatever I got pictures to prove
though yeah but I'm just saying that
in my experience not every dude but yeah
but let's let's say 90 95 of dudes that
I've met and interacted with no matter
what they look like no matter what how
much money they had no matter what their
personality was like thought they were
God's Gift well that's healthy though
that's what kids no I don't know if it
is
I don't know if it's healthy to think
that I think like dial it back like two
notches and then it's healthy okay like
because it's good to have it's good to
have self-confidence because look I'm
coming at it from the total other end of
the scale where I just like I'm totally
not self-confident at all I've gotten
better like over the last few years but
coming at it from the other thing I kind
of feel like people that are too cocky
or too confident I don't think that's
good either and I can't really stand to
be around those kind of people because
they just like irritate the [__] out of
me but it's like being like that is good
but like I said dial it back like like
two notches well you can't be you can't
do what [__] Anton levate was talking
about being so lipstick stick
solipsistic yes yeah solipsistic I'm
drunk well I mean you put an extra tea
in there okay I'm not meaning to be like
a grammar Nazi or anything she's a
[__] Nazi you know how I right you
got you I'm a grammar Nazi you've got a
regular or not yeah okay
if if you're the [__] you better have
you better have a means of [__]
backing it up with something yeah you
can't just like [__] kids out there
and tell people that you're yeah and
then you don't have it because No One's
Gonna believe you don't have any
accomplishments of all me you don't have
any accomplishments or any [__] proof
of it let's see so no
now here's the thing a lot of dudes are
the [__] that's not really that [__]
special
it's not there's a lot of details well
see that's another thing and I'm always
kind of I'm like the kind of person it's
like look you're not that [__]
special nobody's that [__] special
yeah like just be a cool person yeah
like don't go out there and say it's
like I'm the best ever it's like that's
really nah [__] and uh as a dude okay
yeah one of the things one of the things
that I learned is to recognize the the
real key
to understanding the game and advancing
in the game
is recognizing greatness in others when
you see it yeah if you can't recognize
greatness in others then you're a loser
okay and you'll lose sight of Who You
Are
all right
like our friend [__] self
if I see a [__] good-looking dude
I'll [__] record them and [__]
send that [__] to sofa got one over here
for you I'm trying to okay all right
she's like yeah he's hot I said I told
you like I said you need to come down
here man [__] you didn't move down to
Florida with us [__] you'll find a
[__] man here and
you know what I mean but
so you have to be able to recognize
greatness when you see it okay then you
have a better understanding of who you
are and how you fit in all this
okay
everybody has a place it may not be the
place that you want but it's the place
that you got yeah change your place if
you have to worry work on it right you
know
and um that's just not me talking if
you've been on the show long enough I
worked to change my place
okay
if I can got into my late 40s I said
[__] this I don't think I don't like how
I look anymore I just started [__]
going into the gym you start doing
something about it
you will get what you want if you work
hard enough you got the dedication and
[__] you learn how everything is done
and how things work you'll get you
you'll get good results
but it doesn't come easy
but I was never the person that liked
things being easy anyway Jen knows
I like the hard path
I just there's something about it yeah
like being a Native American like being
an Indian going through trials and [__]
oh starting with the audience I'm big
into that [__] like going through some
kind of rite of passage I like that kind
of stuff
joining Cults like [__] biker gangs
and [__]
muscle heads and going to the gym I'm
thinking about [__] I'm gonna have to
go to the Silverbacks that's the [__]
gym where all the [__] Roy had to go
to the name of the gym it's called
Silver [__] backs the only gorillas
there okay although how funny would it
be if it was actually called Silver
[__] back the silver [__] backs
that's what I would have named it silver
[__] backs you never forget nothing
but gorillas
I'm gonna say though
you won't pierce your nipples that will
you no after I pierced Jen's nipples I'm
like I would never do this again
speaking of right of passages I will
never do this again
I put a lot of needles through through
myself and everything you know what I
mean and it's just normal needle action
I had no idea the nipple tissue was that
tough well yeah it was almost like going
through like rubber and like a tire it's
like going through a tire yeah I was
like
I don't know if there was she was
[__] screaming
yeah it hurts so there must have there
must be [__] pain receptors
down underneath well yeah because I mean
if you've ever I mean I'm sure you don't
know where I inject as soon as you go
through the skin there's no pain I mean
I'm sure you don't know about this but
pregnant women yeah a lot of them have
real problems with their uh babies like
a lot of times when the babies are
nursing yeah like they'll their nipples
will be just like constantly sore from
the babies like biting and latching and
like on their nipples like even though
it's like really tough because obviously
it's supposed to be yeah but you know
you have like a little kid [__]
sucking and biting and [__] like that
like all the time like every day yeah
that's gonna [__] your [__] up yeah tell
me your nipples didn't it yeah
yeah I mean it does well but like you
said they were tough to start with yeah
but
um yeah
I I just I don't know I kind of feel
like I did a great job though but I
showed it you did you did do it for my
buddy you guys oh no those are [__]
done real well you did do a good job and
it was so that was the first time I've
done that but I had some experience back
in high school
[__] with vivisection and dissection
courses and [__] so I did that I'm
actually pretty good with [__]
scalpels and
being a cook [__] you know working
with [__] knives a lot you know what
I mean I cut through a lot of flesh but
I didn't know that a nipple was that
tough
and well and like I said I think the
thing that surprised me the most about
it yeah
I knew it was gonna hurt I knew that
like I have a high pain threshold you
guys I do but
the thing that shocked me the most like
when he did the first one is that
I started to black out like on yeah you
know I I didn't know that that was gonna
happen because I was I was sitting up
like on the first one I was sitting up
and like on the um
on the multi-gym thing
and I was sitting up on that and and I
was like and he was doing it like in the
middle of it and I was like I'm gonna
black out I'm a blackout like I'm gonna
like fall backwards and like I did not
expect that to happen at all yeah I
didn't know it was like something out of
the movie the old movie a man called
horse
where [__] his Indian buddies stick
the damn thongs through his [__]
pectoral muscles and suspend him from
the [__] oh yeah that's like that
whole like yeah yeah that's that hole
yeah what is that called
rite of passage I think to become a
warrior
is that you had to be suspended
Yeah by three years yeah you know which
is funny they used just bone and [__]
leather thongs to do it
we got a girlfriend [__] who does
that [__] for fun
Aurora it's just pretty little blonde
you know he's got what [__] three
kids now I think maybe two or three kids
and she but the thing is they're using
steel yeah she has like all piercings
they're about her legs and she'll swing
around and
yeah they push her like and she like
swings way out like just all through the
skin in her back yeah but um
it's probably a lot worse when it's a
piece of bone and not a piece of Steel I
would imagine yeah well I mean like I
said nowadays they have like a lot more
they're a lot more
um health conscious and they're aware of
I mean when you got yeah we did the
piercing at home which I wouldn't
recommend but you got the kit online
yeah um you know you watched a bunch of
videos online like how do you do it it
was like how do you do so you had like
all the [__] no I trained myself yeah
like yeah it came with all the stuff and
it was all you know um sterile and
everything like that and it wasn't the
first time I put a needle through
something it just hurt like a [__] yeah
that's all yeah it wasn't the first time
I put a needle through something I
inject myself all the time I thought it
was gonna be like that but no the gauges
of the needle are big needles are bigger
and you guys they're big and you gotta
[__] switch about one to go through
and then you got to put the [__] bar
through well the needle was what was the
gauge on it because I mean it was the
same size 14 or 16. as the the bars that
are in there now yeah are
big I mean they're they're pretty wide
yeah I haven't like I have other rings
but I haven't switched them out yet
because I'm kind of scared to to be
honest with you yeah well I'll switch
them out for you yeah I bought you a
bunch more I'll switch yeah he bought me
like a whole bag it's like right here
like a different multi-colored ones like
little bars and I also have some hooks
as like or some uh rings as well but I
haven't like switched them out because
like I said but the captured ball rings
are hard though you need a tool to [__]
and put them back right I don't know if
I'm excited about that but like it's
healed now so it's just kind of like I
no a lot of times I kind of like forgot
they're in there yeah but
every time I see them though I'm always
just kind of like I'm glad I did it like
it sucked at the time I'm not gonna lie
to you
um it was very very painful and it's
like after you did the first one
and you were saying you saw the other
day that you saw like a porn video or
something like that and the girl just
had one yeah and I went out immediately
and she was like and she's like oh she
just got one it was like [__] that which
like I said I thought about that because
you did the one and I was like I don't
even know if I want to do the other one
because man that sucked a lot yeah but
then I was like man I'm I don't I don't
want to be uneven yeah I don't I don't
like being
you know she did it asymmetrical yeah so
she did something I wouldn't do
see so that's pretty you know
I'm more of an endurance guy but [__]
when it's just something like putting
this damn putting a piercing through
your [__] nipple I'm like nah no
thanks
that's not something I exactly I've
absolutely had to do
but I tell you what man that was a great
upgrade visually the photographs it
looks really it looks really good I
think that it gives I think it was worth
it they're straight and they're nice and
deep
so the way they they they hold it you
guys can see the photos if you ever join
us on streamate but uh no they look
great yeah I really like that yeah
I don't know if I'd do it again show
them to build no you didn't but showed
them to bill my uh porn producer buddy
and he used to be an ex an ex piercer
and he's like oh yeah that's a great job
it's your first job of the yeah because
that's really good
I marked them
you know well like I said the kit comes
without they're all sterile it comes
with like the marker and the thing where
you pull the nipple out and like all
that no the markers were separate oh
okay so it came with the tool though
right where you pull the thing out and
like [__] yeah and it came with all
different gauges you could put whatever
gauge you wanted in there so I didn't
use that tool I used my hand
yeah
because that tool was bothering you
remember when I was gonna went in there
and I was like okay [__] it I'm just
gonna I don't need that I just want to
use my hand put it through let's change
the subject though that's the kind of
normal subject people are talking in
there [__] Victor showed up what's up
Victor hey Victor what's been turning
you gay lately
everything makes Victory yeah Victor
shows up and hearing he [__] names
all these dudes oh man [__] yeah uh
[__] Tom Hardy turned me gay
and then like like did he go like yeah
his his back arch turned me gay and then
like a week that could turn anybody
again then he's like [__] needs
somebody else [__] Tony Curtis turned
me gay it probably turns you guys just
like looking at it yeah who
Tom Hardy's butt angle oh yeah that
turned me good are you sure straight as
[__] I'm going to print that out and
frame it and put it over our bed and see
how you feel
well remember how we said that we were
gonna do you guys know what we're
talking about man [__] a couple weeks
back our friend Zach who he was in the
comment section here a while ago yeah
he's here he's still here all right Zach
sent me he's talking about the Bee Gees
yeah he's talking about Zach sent me a
[__] photograph on messenger like an
old picture an old picture from Tom
Hardy's old MySpace page which should
give you a clue and he's laying on the
bed nude
I didn't know this okay but this is how
Tom Hardy used to be he's laying on a
bed nude touching the mirror next to him
and his back arch is better than any
female porn star like he can't see his
dick or nothing yeah you can just see
his butt and he's just backwards his
butt and I'm like man that dude
motherfucker's ready for all comers all
right he's just [__] this he's gonna
get ready to go anal it's like
it was a cool picture it was a female it
was like it was it was a it was in a
feminate position but it made him famous
in the gay scene evidently now this is
back before it was it was the Tom Hardy
that you know he wasn't royed it out yet
he didn't he wasn't Bane he didn't
become [__] um [__] uh Bronson or
none of that [__] happened yet he was
still in his uh
skinny uh raver Club boy
mode which that's cool too yeah he
probably weighed about 130 pounds Maybe
140.
but he sent me this picture and I was
like [__] that's Tom Hardy and then
[__] Jenny saw that [__] and she her
eyes were like going
you know I was like look at that holy
[__] yeah how is he even doing that no I
can't do that no but I you know
as a straight man I saw it and
understood like I said earlier you must
recognize greatness when you see it uh
that's what I like about it
right you took a good picture and you
don't have that weird like homophobic
thing that a lot of straight teeth nah
he took a good picture and uh women and
gays responded to it and [__] uh
probably got a job probably got his
probably got a job because that picture
I was impressed by the butt angle it was
very impressive it almost didn't look
real
it was I mean I know it was I know it
was but it's like it almost feel like
right the Zack send me that picture
again I'll show it I'll show it since
we've already been demand sized
Victor says 1993 Keanu Reeves made me
gay today yeah okay now Keanu Reeves
making you gay okay wait wait what was
he doing in 1993 like refresh my memory
uh 93 that would have been that would
have been [__] uh The Matrix right
was it
I don't remember when the first Matrix
might have been 94-95 huh maybe I don't
remember 93 that would have been that
would have been speed right
I've got the bus with the bus the bus
and the bomb maker yeah was this Sandra
Bullock in that Sandra Bullock Sandra
Bullock's cute little ass she was cute
she's cute but it's like something about
her always like annoyed me
it's her personality I think she's very
vanilla the the characters that she was
trying to play were very vanilla kind of
something about her mask on my nerves
kind of All-American kind of innocent
girl I don't like that she was hanging
out with [__] um uh the dude from
West Coast Shoppers what was his name or
uh no uh
what's his name [__] Jesse James
Jesse James yeah Jesse James was her
boyfriend and that [__] was a
dick if you ask me he seemed like a dick
I mean I don't know the dude but it's
like he always like came off like a dick
like honestly yeah and evidently he
[__] like got rid of her he was like
yeah that's right there's the whole
thing didn't like her and like [__]
like get out of here yeah
although I can't blame him too much for
that like I said I don't know either of
them so I'm just talking out my ass but
it's like
something about her Sandra Bullock got
on my nerves she like she's pretty I get
that but it's just kind of like
something about her personality was just
very grating to me Tammy said speed was
94 okay so but what came out in 93 then
I don't know
all right Tammy said he was a male model
Tom Hardy yeah yeah okay
John Robertson said I sent it to you
Jenny those are the um the art with
Peter Cushing on it okay to my email
so I'll check it like after the show
hope it gets to you with no problems I'm
sure it did it's uh I'm sure it's fine
as well as my plants my Halloween
costume which
Victor tell you about that Victor man I
don't understand why you know I don't
know if this is racism or what or but
you're blaming you're gayness on all
these anglo-american guys it's gonna be
[__] Keanu Reeves or it's going to be
well actually actually
Tom Hardy's not anglo-american he's a
straight up Anglo so he's from England
okay
motherland yeah he's back in the hockey
motherland you know what I mean I I
don't know why you want to blame all
these white guys for your
proclivities you're gonna talk about
[__] well I mean might as well it's
just you know maybe you got they kind of
[__] everything you might have that
Asian [__] can't go [__] uh you're
trying to look for that Anglo experience
you know [__] kind of like oh Steven
Seagal and his Asian experience I don't
understand it's just got to be some kind
of
fetish it's a fetish
leave them white boys alone
they didn't make you gay
well something did clearly made himself
gay his lust made him gay I mean it just
happens yeah
Tammy said much to do about nothing came
out in 1983 with keanuary I totally
forgot he was in that
oh my God like wait a minute I remember
kind of liking that movie but
one I forgot that Keanu Reeves was in it
for one thing
two did he try to have a British accent
in it again because
why
Victor says now my type is 21 Latino two
1991 Keanu Reeves Point Break oh yeah
yeah Point Break
wait was Patrick Swayze in that one too
is that the one I'm thinking of
like I said it's all a blur
the 90s were all a [__] blur that was
just like after I graduated from high
school
I graduated in 1990 so after that it was
just kind of like
college and
going to shows all the time and
I don't remember most of the 90s is is
what I'm saying
but what I remembered of it I didn't
like
now okay so much to do about nothing was
that the one with what's his [__]
name the dude that's in like all the
Shakespeare
that real pretentious [__] who
is also kind of I hate to admit it but
also like a good actor what the [__] is
that dude's name
he did the Frankenstein movie
it's right in the tip of my tongue
someone will probably remind me Kenneth
Brana Kenneth Brana
was Kenneth Brana in that
or was I or am I thinking about
something else
because I did see a lot of those
Shakespeare adaptations and I liked
those but
Kenneth Brana like
he did all those Shakespeare adaptations
and he's look look I'm grudgingly
admitting that he's like a really good
actor but God damn it it's like I don't
know if I want to hang out with a dude
in real life because what dude Kenneth
Brana because he seems like um
like a pretentious douche like almost
Bono level but I'm not I don't know if
I'd go that far but I think we reviewed
remember we did not too long ago we did
Kenneth brana's version of Frankenstein
yeah which I will admit is the most
faithful to the novel like they even
have the whole [__] with like the Arctic
Circle and all that kind of [__] with as
far as I know like other Frankenstein
adaptations don't have that
but Kenneth Branagh the whole scene
where he's creating the monster and he's
just like I have to be shirtless for
this and for some reason and you know
he's just like writhing around in the
lab like all [__] showing off his
pecs and he's like covering slime and
stuff like that I'm like really Kenneth
Brown is this really
really what you're doing
um you know what I mean so I don't know
I have a love-hate relationship with him
but I don't know if he did what much to
do about nothing because I can't
remember so Victor Garcia's he's backing
off on his second anglophet and she goes
no no he liked the 20 20 Latino guys and
also said it was 1991 keanuary okay I'm
just gonna let you stay straight okay
you set it straight okay
don't come at me with all this [__] that
Keanu Reeves made you gay back in 91 and
[__] well you asked him though what made
you gay today Tom Hardy
yeah you're playing blame it on all
these white dudes see so I'm getting
insecure about it you know what I mean
I'm getting like why are you blaming my
people for your good people all right
here's the question for you Tom yeah
what's up what made you straight I don't
know man because I can't remember
becoming straight I was just straight
from the very beginning I remember being
a little kid
being real young and looking at my mom's
friends [__] her boobs and going man
I [__] she got some nice titties and
I'd be like [__] five you know what I
mean it's just the way it was
I had kind of a confused upbringing
because when I was young well you know
how I yeah I do but it's like because
when I was a kid yeah I was super into
you're gonna You're gonna laugh at me
well you already know this
um My First Crush I think was Lurch from
that yeah yeah it's like funny so I was
like into that but I was also related
like my dad always had like porn
magazines around yeah like Playboy and
Penthouse and stuff and I was also
really into like the chicks in there
okay yeah so um so that was a thing and
um I don't know I guess I think uh the
whole straight action
happened when you know I was a little
kid and uh my mom was sending him to my
babysitter
and that would be like [__]
um Kimmy and Kimmy was probably about 13
or 14 and she'd take me to like uh
um
sleepovers with all her friends
and it'd be like
five or six or seven of these girls
would be like between the ages of like
and uh maybe 13.
and they'd put on Led Zeppelin albums of
smoke pot California and [__] I was
the Pookie basically
[__] like getting a sleeping bag and
you know what I mean it never just me
and they're little kids yeah because
those little kids you know and they're
like oh look at everybody's so cute you
know and then they take you to take me
to the movies and [__]
because uh that's just the way it was
back in the 70s
when you had my mom was hot you know
[__] their 20s and she'd [__] hand
me over to the neighborhood girls that
would take care of me and she'd pay him
you know here I'm gonna go out and do
yeah I'm gonna go out go ahead
here take take time so you know I was
kind of like uh and which is good for
little kids you there shouldn't really
be around their parents all the time uh
well they need other and these other
influences and other
you know kids because Kimmy and all her
little girlfriends were kids
to me they were older women but they
were a little 12 13 year olds you know
and their their whole thing really back
in the 70s is that they made babysitters
you know you give your baby to them and
they'd
play with the baby and [__] give them
all kinds of attention and [__]
hopefully not put them in the microwave
but no no no they're good they're a good
little like um
1970s uh Disco
[__] chicks you know they were little
little girls but you know we're
listening to disco and
Led Zeppelin and Pink Floyd and [__] and
smoking pot
which is what they did
you hear him [__] doing girl talk
talking about boys you know and I was
old enough to know what they were
talking about boys so you know it's just
kind of how I was introduced to um
sexuality
three little girls
that's probably good though because you
actually like listen to what yeah I'm
listening what they're saying you know
I'm [__] you know which a lot of
dudes don't do no and it's always like
affection and you know and they're
they're hugging you and [__] passing
you from one girl the next it's not
sexual
but it's it's you know what I mean
that's not what they're doing but it's
all just about affection so you're kind
of like bonding so that's probably and
that's the default setting for guys
anyways you know and just for people is
to be heterosexual that's really just
the default in the animal kingdom and uh
that was what was reinforced
I don't know why people are gay uh
there's a lot of different theories it
could be partially genetics it could be
partially just luck well it happens
early in other animals as well yeah just
I don't I don't know anything about that
but it just could be
just early experiences
um
I don't know fixations on certain things
to where that's just how the
the sexuality really the most of the
data suggests it has something to do
with how many sons your mom's had that's
one of the things that that is one
Factory yeah yeah but like I said
there's a lot of I think it's genetic
and the thing about it is that like I
said it's almost kind of like
as much as I was
um like I said into Lurch from The Adams
Family and then later I got into like
Duran Duran and stuff like Simon Lebon
particularly the rest of them I was
still kind of like well Nick Rhodes was
kind of hot too but it's like that but I
was also into girls too you know what I
mean like at least like aesthetically
like looking at
women are better looking uh in general I
think they're more pleasing to look at
than average guys yeah I agree and like
yeah I kind of feel like if I'm gonna do
that yeah if I'm gonna like look at them
like just aesthetically like for just a
pleasure kind of thing it's gonna be
like a woman yeah
although you know
you go back in history
in the Greek Golden Era and [__] in
the Greek age and even the Greco-Roman
age [__] guys were held up as the
Pinnacle of beauty if you didn't look
like a man then you were ugly
so maybe certain things go in and out of
style maybe that was something just in
certain city-states believe that you
know I don't know
but uh and I'm not saying that like
dudes can't be like aesthetically
pleasing I'm more work yeah I'm just
saying that if if I'm gonna find
somebody aesthetically plea just from a
pure because like I said I'm I'm not
kind of I'm That Kind of [__]
that it's like I don't really find you
attractive unless I know you you know
what I mean so if I'm just gonna like
look at a picture of somebody and be
like yeah they're hot or whatever it's
almost like 95 of the time it's gonna be
a woman
yeah because I just you know what I mean
I just I just find them like better to
look at yeah but you know that's what
but like I said it all bets are off if I
know the person
because if you know the person then a
whole other uh series of things comes
into play you know because you know that
person yeah but if it's just like
physical stuff then yeah it's probably
gonna be a woman
um Camp guy said my hottest porn stars
are those that remind me of gals from
times past like she looks just like Kate
Capshaw and Raiders or she looks just
like that gal in my high school junior
biology class I'm gonna say well can't
capture for one thing she was in the
second she wasn't a Raiders of Lost Ark
she was in
Temple of Doom she was screaming as [__]
and she was man she was she was
attractive but man she was [__]
annoying yeah she was like the worst
part of that movie we went back and
watched those movies and really only the
first one is is good I mean people say
well all of them are good
I remembered liking
Temple of Doom the best I did too well
they went back and watched it the
heart's tearing out I was like I was
into that went back and watched it
though and I was like nah this movie
isn't that good
um well it's mostly because of her yeah
she's screaming all the time and it's
just I just wanted to know like I wanted
to punch her like right in the [__]
tank and the third one the third one was
a little odd
the best one was the first one
well yeah and the fourth one was [__]
ridiculous and the fifth one they say is
posted it's coming out soon it's
supposed to be even worse all right you
know what I've heard
dial of Destiny you're talking about
yeah I've heard that most of the reviews
that I've seen of it like of the people
that have seen it that early yeah
um they said it's pretty good they said
it's it's better than Crystal Skull
right which like I said that's kind of a
low bar to clear I get that um because
crystal skull with a great but they're
saying well it's better than that
they're like as an indie movie it's fine
no that's that's what I've heard it's
fine so it's not fantastic yeah but
better than Crystal Skull which is
really all you can do at this stage I'm
skeptical I mean [__]
he's pretty old
yeah he's pretty old you know [__] um
that ship's kind of sailed if you ask me
yeah they might have left it slightly
too late yeah they should have made this
I mean it's a long time I mean I do like
that character but I don't I don't know
I kind of feel like he's probably like
too old to be playing they should have
been made they should have been making
those movies a long time ago
you know when
within you know within 10 years
yeah I mean if you're gonna do it you're
gonna do them do them way back then
oh just nah
Sir John Day the great says bonobos can
be gay in open relationships yet that's
true chimps are violent bonobo chimps
chill and have sex all day we are
decedent from both the duality of man
yeah bonobos are much more
um they [__] everybody they're all in
open relationships gay you straight
whatever they're yeah they're pervs they
are well that's how well that's how
whereas a chimpanzee will settle uh
beefs by killing and eating another
tribe yeah of chips bonobos will just
[__] the other tribe and everything's
fine that's what I mean it's an
oversimplification but that's generally
the way they work they use sex as like a
social
lubricant if you want to say it that way
that's basically how they do it they
don't instead of they do fight I'm not
saying that but um that's usually how
they settle their Advanced they're an
advanced creature though and there's no
telling
if that's
because they're I think they're the same
species
The Chimps they're very very cool
they're just a subspecies they're very
close so you might be more dealing with
culture and tradition than you are
anything else well they are different
species they thought they were the same
species no they're not the same species
not at all but they're very little
crossbreed
um as far as I know they cannot okay
not and not um I mean not any more than
like a human and a chimp good okay
as far as I'm aware I thought they could
cross breed with you and you know humans
and chimps are what 98 similar but we're
also 98 similar to bonobos but it was
there was a there was a fork
several like three million years ago
four Millions I can't remember but um I
read a couple books about a long time
ago it's been a while but um but yeah so
they split off like three or four
million so there are technically
different species because they can't
interbreed but um yeah bonobos generally
they do fight
um but they generally solve a lot of
their issues through
sex mutual masturbation that kind of
stuff
oh they're asking if I remember V yeah I
remember V yeah somebody asked us about
that that on uh Wednesday's show I think
yeah I kind of remember that show for
Vendetta he's talking about a series
yeah visitor
there's about some aliens that came to
Earth
turns out they were lizard people
underneath masks they were doing [__] I
remember it but I don't remember I don't
think I saw all of it all right I'm
gonna pee I think I only saw some of it
so uh
but yeah I do remember it
I remember a lot of those series from
back then I remember mostly battle the
old Battle Star Galactica remember that
one although I haven't seen it in so
long I really only remember certain
episodes I don't remember how the whole
story arc went
you remember remember uh what was it
called
Jason of Star Command remember that [__]
I think they had Sig heads I think it
was Sig Haze in that played the [__]
bat Baltar I think now what was that do
today
oh
I remember uh
Buck Rogers Buck Rogers in the 21st
century
uh
uh some old [__] 70s movie Arc
remember Arc two
so they had the people that were going
through the post-apocalyptic [__]
world in that damn RV with all the
[__] wheels on it and then talking
chimp
remember uh Shazam I remember uh
[__] Atlanta lost
there's a movie called Damnation Alley I
don't remember that one it was kind of
like Arc too in a way
uh Unfortunately they remade V in 2009
oh man
foreign
do you got your glasses on the room yeah
my glasses are right here
we're talking about V
I know like I remember watching some of
that back in the day but it's like
2009. yeah I remember hearing about that
yeah
I mean I remember liking the original
series but I haven't seen it like
since then
so that might be something we'd have to
like revisit
yeah John Robertson said I heard that uh
Robert Eggers version of Nosferatu has
finished production yeah Tammy um it was
is she still here she was in the
comments earlier but yeah she sent me
the um
like not the trailer but like a um like
an article about it that they had
finished they had wrap production on it
and I'm really really want to see that
because
I've liked everything Robert Edwards has
done is I love [__] Nosferatu
and I think that he is like the ideal
person to do that because he's very very
into
making stuff like as authentic as
possible so I think that's Gonna Roll
it's like hopefully hopefully
you know what I mean and I'm super like
I love the original nosferati look I
have the poster from like the [__]
Klaus Kinski one back there with
Isabella Johnny and stuff so I love that
poster
I like the original one better than
the remake
but
that one was still pretty weird it
wasn't like really the same but you know
what I mean
uh
yeah so
the Remake was not in a good will
remake was not any good I figure
I guess not because I never [__] hear
about it
yeah Tammy said she was still here yeah
I mean
I don't know when
uh uh the nasrachi Remake is coming [__]
man I still haven't seen Renfield I need
to [__] watch that
all of the movies that I was like
looking forward to seeing this year I
was thinking about this I don't think I
ever made it but it's like I was
thinking about doing a video for my
other channel like scary Salon I was
like oh the five most anticipated horror
movies this year it's like I think I've
only seen one of them I think Barbarian
is like the only one that I actually
ended up watching like the other ones I
haven't even seen him yet and like
[__]
um
brenfield was one of them and I still
haven't [__] seen that even though
Tammy saw it and she said it was awesome
and it's like I've seen like a lot of
other people talking about how it was
awesome and I just like really wanted to
see it also Voyage of the demeanor but I
don't think that's coming out until
September or October like I said
Facebook what this time we've been on
for over three hours I'm so [__]
hungry yeah I got that Curry down there
oh that's right yeah you've got Kurt I
got Curry down there maybe we should go
eat them Curry yeah let's get something
to eat I am very hungry I just came home
and just like had yeah I'm gonna start
heating up I'll see you guys around and
start getting something to eat eating up
stuff to eat for Jen yeah and um we'll
see you guys win Sunday Sunday now we'll
either
on Sunday what what's the matter
she just went ah
I don't know what she's talking about
um we'll either talk about
uh for the Sunday review we'll either
talk about Wonder Woman because we
watched that last night or if we don't
go out tomorrow night and watch another
movie tomorrow night then it will be
some mystery movie that we even we don't
know what it is so we'll find out but we
did watch Wonder Woman last night so if
we don't watch another movie tomorrow
night we might talk about that one but
it might be a different one we'll see
how it goes because that was like pretty
good it was the one from 2017. you know
what I mean
so hopefully you guys have a good rest
of your evening we're gonna go eat some
Curry and drink the rest of our drinks
and
probably fall asleep because
I've been up I've been up since
quarter to five this morning so I'm
still kind of going and it's a whole
thing but yeah so
have a good day tomorrow you guys and we
will see you for a movie review on
Sunday evening so hope you hopefully you
guys can all join us for that and we'll
see you then good night